hey everybody it's Bill Burr and guess
what it's that time of year when you can
say it's the Patrice O'Neal benefit
announcement the 11th annual Patrice
O'Neal Comedy benefit uh is going to be
Tuesday March 26th at the New York City
Center 131 West 55th Street between 6th
and 7th Avenue in New York City doors
open at 700 p.m. show starts at 7:30
p.m. hey Bill what's the lineup this
year we have SNL head rder Michael Chay
we got Tim Dylan we got Marcelo
Hernandez Bonnie mcfallen Shan Patton
Robert Powell III Cipher sounds Rich
Voss and yours truly truly plus we have
a very special guest we have a very no
it says we might have a special guest no
we have a special guest we have somebody
to come out there kick you right in the
dick this is a serious thing for Moren
Taran who puts this thing together every
single year for 11 years she absolutely
crushes it crushes it on the social
media we we sell out every year because
of her um she's the best so I just want
to take time you know it's a new year to
say thank you to Moren Taran um tickets
go on sale today at 12: PM eastern time
all tickets a 75 big ones 75 bucks and
um I think that's it tickets can be
purchased online at New York
nycitycenter.org
Patrice 2024 or by calling the box
office at 212 5811 1212 that number
again is 212 5811 1212 this is one of my
favorite things um you know Patrice was
just the best and we get to keep his
name alive we get to help out his mom
and uh it's also like a nice standup
reunion because I don't get to see a lot
of these guys uh these men and women
okay that's it I'll see you on uh in
March what did I say the 24th
where the hell is the goddamn copy here
the 26th
sorry all right thank
you hey what's going on it's Bill Burr
and it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in
checking in all you uh how's it going
how are you oh boy here we go it's
another one it's another another
year yep January 11th it's real people
it's happening again you're starting a
new
semester you've gone back to
work you're back to eating Donuts do you
know what I cannot [__] get off my
mind is you know right during the
holidays Oh Billy no no that's what I
was oh no no no I don't want that I
don't want this I don't want that all
right old Billy Beach B in the [__]
winter time that's when I do it I don't
do it during the summertime when you
look good I do it during the winter time
when you're wearing a big puffy coat
nobody even knows nobody even knows
you're in shape and then when it counts
when it [__] matters that's when I
start eating barbecue and I come become
Billy fat tits by May and just people
just you know they just have this idea
of me that's it's just not true okay I
am Billy fat tits in the
summer but the winter I'm in
shape um that was kind of how my
academic career went like I [__] did
great in all the grades that college
doesn't pay attention to I did great
[__] first through fifth grade sixth
grade seventh you know started taking on
water eighth maintained
and then ninth grade right through
[__] high school I just I just [__]
the bed and uh then here I sit talking
to myself on a
podcast
um anyway you know what drives me up the
[__] wall and I don't this is not
like something I haven't heard in a long
time is when another adult that I don't
work with not work that I don't work
for tells me to hang tight
I don't know what it is about that
expression probably because my dad used
to say hey hang tight hey hang tight hey
[__] you it's just I just think that to
this day hang tight okay Sarge what did
I join the [__] I joined your
army could you hang on a second could
you just do me a favor could you just
hang on I like that hang tight like I'm
sitting there waiting for my [__]
orders G I don't know I know why it
really has nothing to do with the people
that say it cuz I love the people that
are telling me to hang tight but if they
knew like you know I'm like a [__]
rescue dog like this you
know you get a rescue dog you have no
idea right you put your foot up on a
[__] couch and all of a sudden it
just loses its
[__] everybody's got that everybody I I
I'm this is what I'm doing cuz I'm out
of my [__] mind I'm going to say
everybody does it too so I feel more
normal maybe I maybe maybe you guys
don't is it what what thing does
somebody say to you that just [__]
sets you
off hang tight is
is you know I don't know but it it's for
me that's it's kind of like a hit song
like pop music you know every couple of
weeks there's a new number one so right
now top of the charts for
me is uh hang
tight honorable mentions uh uh go into
your settings
could you okay could you just go into
your
settings could you go into your settings
all right hang tight I'm going to go
into your
settings
um not a
fan not a fan at all um anyway uh I
don't know what to start with I mean I
got to start with the biggest [__]
story in my world right now Nick
Sabin is
retiring the great Nick Sabin seven
count them seven
NCAA
titles without a doubt one of the
greatest to ever do it you could argue
the greatest I mean he's in the
conversation does he have more than Bear
Bryant combined I don't know I didn't
look any of this [__] up but
uh I had so much fun rooting against
him always respected him but Jesus
Christ did I have fun rooting against
Alabama it was so much [__] fun and
uh I feel like when I watched when I
rooted against Nick Sabin you know
watching LSU and
everything uh I you know I knew what
football fans felt like rooting against
Bill
bich it's just like you just felt like
your team had to play a perfect game
mistake free football one [__]
mistake and it was it was just over over
the next thing you know you're getting
choked out you [__] tap out and you
lost the game and you're like what just
happened
um unreal and I feel uh privileged as a
sports fan that I attended his last game
we shall see I don't know I saw some
places saying rumors say that he's
retiring and everybody else told me that
he's retiring got all these text
messages so it must have become official
at some point during the day I'm uh in
the process
of uh writing another script here with a
buddy of mine Ben tishler who did I did
old dad's with so we're right in another
one having a good time doing that so I
was kind of in the
bubble today and all of a sudden my
phone just blew up unbelievable and
sneaky Peak
Carol I don't know if it was am amicable
I imagine it was I don't think that he
was on the hot seat or anything he has
decided to uh take his talents to South
Beach or whatever he's doing maybe he's
retiring I have no idea but the guy's
like 72 73 years
old and like he's like the [__] MC
Jagger of head coaches I mean he is like
in ridiculous ridiculous shape so I feel
like he's going to land somewhere else
and and anybody's going to be lucky to
have that guy CU that guy that guy's a
winner definitely a winner
um wow so who get who gets the
job who gets the job at Alabama um and
also you know just a complete
lack of warning that that was even
coming must be a
shocker
um and tuscalosa I know I know the
feeling I all of a sudden Tom Brady Tom
Brady
signs with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers I
will never forget that day I was like
wow it is
over it is officially
over um which you knew was going to
happen you just didn't know it was going
to be that
abrupt uh which is why if you're
fortunate enough to have somebody like
that coaching or playing for you or
whatever uh to try to enjoy every second
of the ride because one day one day it's
it's [__]
over
um
anyway last
night uh or yesterday I just had like a
[__] an amazing day had an amazing
day hi hung out with my family took the
kids to school you know did a little
helicopter
ride
um realized how much I love Los Angeles
and how it's one of the most
misunderstood cities there's so much
cool [__] to do out here so much
incredible food so many amazing
people but uh you
know Hollywood and all these [__]
people in the award shows ruined it over
the years trying to Ram their [__]
politics Kicks Down people's throats and
now everybody hates it you
know um I'm telling you don't don't
listen of that [__] it's [__] it's an
incredible
city
um and then uh I went to the uh what are
they calling it now the Avalon used to
be called the
uh not was it called the paramont I
think it was called the
paramont basically the place where I did
my first standup gig
ever um Lou Anderson rest his soul Louis
Anderson's comedy showcase and I went
out and I did my little five six seven
minute set they shot it during the day
it was in front of a touristy crowd and
people were not having good
sets and uh I went out
there I remember I had bought some new
shoes that I thought were
nice um I was not going to Doc Martins
were really in and I really loved doc
Martins but I knew I just wasn't a Doc
Martin guy Doc Martin were the the were
were the
choice of Shu for the future alternative
Comics The
Writers the smart you know men and women
that did standup you know that uh you
know wrote the perfect jokes and uh I
was you know I was a
screamer you know I was an energy guy so
I was like ah I don't fit in that quad
so as much as I liked them I bought I
forget what the [__] they were something
Hugo or something not Hugo Boss I forget
what they were they probably defunked I
don't know I remember I bought those and
it was a big deal making that decision
cuz I didn't have any [__] money and
they were like 90 bucks and I bought
them that was my big thing and I went
out and I did the show and like I said
people were having tough sets and
uh I went up there and I fortunately was
doing material about my family so it
really it the first joke landed I
remember that it landed with the uh
touristy
crowd and you know I was working totally
clean and I was talking about my family
and I looked like I was 12 years old so
they liked me and I had a good set and I
remember great Louie Anderson I couldn't
believe I was going to meet him he came
walking
out cuz he had one of my favorite
stand-up specials of the80s the one
where he wore the red coat sport coat
and uh he was talking about his fish hey
Louie give me a jelly donut Louie you
know and uh and I also loved his his
pacing and his storytelling he was just
he would that guy was a [__] master
so I did my set it went well and he came
walking out and I still remember he's
going keep it going for
Billy right and
uh and then he leans in and he looked at
me with a dead serious Su on his face
and he goes you're going to be a big
star and I was just like
wow it's going to happen man I knew it I
knew four five years I was going to make
it you know [__] smash cut 10 years
later I'm in a comedy condo looking at
the oven going you know just turn it on
stick your head in
there or you got to do the third show
tonight at whatever the [__] I was at um
anyway and that's also the place where
Andrew Dice Clay did his first hourlong
special I think it was called The Dice
Man cometh and then they also had all of
these there was some um TV show that
they filmed there way back in the day I
used to know the history but there's all
these black and white photos in there
people like you know Dean Martin and
Ethel Merman and all these people Louie
Armstrong all of those people from like
the Golden Age Dean Martin and all of
that stuff so last night I went down
there and uh Dean Del re once again put
together this killer show for his Bon
Scott tribute show which the last time
we did it it was literally the day
before they shut down everything for the
pandemic and uh we were finally going to
he was finally going to bring it back
next year and unfortunately his rock and
roll mom passed away he said some really
nice things about her and all the rock
and roll moms like his mom this is how
cool Dean's mom was she took him to see
ACDC on like the Highway to Hell Tour or
the power age tour I forget what um she
also took him to go see uh he saw him oh
no wait yeah yeah he saw him in outside
of San Francisco in Oakland I
think and saw like Judas Priest and
Randy rhods and all these people it was
amazing um so anyways the show
starts it's such a great show you got if
you're in anywhere near La you got to
come it's kind of the Perfect Blend of
uh
standup and uh you know ACDC I mean what
what's what's wrong with that
combination nothing in my world so um
did stand up first guy up was Jim
Florentine who flew in to check you know
just to watch the show which is awesome
and Dean was like you want to go up he
was like yeah and he was [__]
hilarious as always but like literally
the funniest I've seen Jim and he's
always killed me and uh you know I was
up there listening my wife was laughing
her ass off which you know she grew up
around comedians so she's like a
comedian so if she's laughing like
someone's killing so he killed and then
Dean went up and killed and I went up
and I tried some of my new stuff and
that works I was already on a high it
was funny I kind of felt like that was
the pressure part of the show was over
because you know no one expects me to be
good on drums but like I I'm a comedian
so I have to be good and you
know you're not really thinking about it
like during rehearsals and stuff when
you're playing with the band and
everything then all of a sudden at night
all the all these [__] people show up
and you're like oh my God here we go
right and
um so anyway I'm [__]
uh I do my set and we go to
uh we go to um oh God damn it who's
texting
me um all right let the text go uh
so anyway then there it's a 15 minute
break you know and then we're g Dean's
like we're gonna do the show right and
he had all these [__] sick ass
pictures of Bon Scott and like banners
and then he had like Malcolm Young up
there too I mean it was just [__]
insane and like that was my band when I
was growing up it's still my band I
absolutely [__] love him Phil rud's
like one of my favorite drummers of all
time and it's just was just another one
of those things if you told the [__]
15-year-old me that I'd be doing this
show I would be losing my mind so anyway
the show was uh I hope I remember
everybody Dean was singing on rhythm
guitar was Billy
row uh from Buck Cherry uh Scott Ian
from Anthrax Josh Z was doing the anger
stuff absolutely murdered and then Steve
Gorman was was the drummer from the
bagman and black crows Dave
Lombardo um
Suicidal Tendencies and of course Slayer
Josh free from everybody and the Foo
Fighter so it's like you know three of
my favorite
drummers um Scotty and's wife uh Pearl
sang on a couple and she sang Dirty
deeds and uh and backup on like night
Prowler and everything and then my
dumbass oh and Larry Lon from uh Primus
came on for I think a whole lot of Rosie
so uh I couldn't see the set list right
so Steve Gorman goes up there and the
guy is just like [__] is solid as
just killing [__] killing he's a
mountain of a man just a [__] big
dude 6'4 and he's just smashing up there
and just driving the band I love
watching that guy play just drives the
band and everybody's [__] locked in
and then all of a sudden I'm like wait a
minut I got to [__] go up but I got
to play two songs so I played
um what's next to the moon and walk all
over you and I was hoping we were going
to do walk all over you first because I
could kind of warm up cuz it sort of
medium Tempo and then but walk all over
you was like [__] you know it's a
fast song for me anyway so of course uh
you know I'm
doing what elich tells me to do is like
you don't got to [__] sit there
warming up on a pad you know how to play
like do some jumping jack skip rope so I
felt stupid doing jumping jacks I just
kept walking up and down the stairs you
know my heart rate's going or whatever
you want to be a little like feel you
want to come out there and feel like you
already played three songs so I was
doing that [__] people looking at me
asking what the [__] I'm doing and
people kept talking to me and I kept
going like I I got to I got to do this
so I don't go out there and [__] this up
and then I had friends that were there
were going to watch me play and then all
of a sudden I was like wait a minute
this is the pressure part of the show I
know how to be a
comedian so we went up there I go up
there and then of
course um we do walk all over you
first and uh and then we did what's next
to the moon and
um I can't I got to tell you man I I I
know I messed up here or there but it
kind of was the best I've ever played
and I've always hit like not as hard as
I I I thought I always feel like I'm
killing it and then I watch myself and I
look like I'm playing like I'm asking
questions like am I doing it right is it
okay and that one last night you know
usually when I watch video of myself
playing DRS like I just cringe like oh
God shut it off shut it off no no you
know but the only way you learn like
when I first started being a comedian I
thought I was like up there looking like
a pro and taking all these pauses and I
would just be [__] like looking like
a pinball going back and forth flop
sweat all of this stuff I was like oh my
God I look like an
[__] and um I actually watched the
video and it looked all right and I got
you know I got some nice compliments and
everything so the first one went off
with without a
hitch and then uh you know I'm counting
off uh what's next to the moon and it's
just got that weird you know one two
three four
one you [__] hitting all the ants on
the crash symbol oh it's just really
just [__]
weird stuff but um and then it also sort
of rides out on the album so you know we
decided the end of the song I think Josh
Z came up that we would just come back
to that in the end and uh that one
[__] went off without a hitch and I
was kind of like I think that went
pretty good and uh as I was getting off
stage Josh free like hugged me and
everything and you know Dave lomard all
these [__] Heroes of mine would you
know they said that was really that was
[__]
solid which that like was like the the
greatest compliment I could have ever
got
and
uh I got off stage and then and then
after that then I got to right after I
finished like I couldn't even
like really take it in how psyched I
was that it went so well and then like
cuz I wanted to watch Josh and Josh went
up and played what did he play he played
Dirty Deeds he [__] of course crushed
it and then Dave Lombardo went up and he
played I want to say whole lot the Jack
and whole lot of Rosie which was amazing
because it was like something so slow
and then something so uptempo and of
course he effortlessly handled both and
uh and then Steve Gorman took like who
played the first five songs and took
like a six song Break went up and uh
played on the last one night
Prowler and uh oh dude it was great we
went out there and uh you know Gibson
was nice enough to uh donate a uh an SG
I think through the the Bon Scott family
or whatever like it's kind of like they
they pay attention to it like Dean like
knows them and everything and
um you know we gave away some stuff to
people in the crowd and the [__]
crowd was
amazing and I was kind of nervous when
of course I was nervous I went up there
I was thinking like you know walk all
over you and what's next to the moon
like I was like these are really like
ACDC nerd deep cut like [__]
songs and I couldn't believe the energy
of the crowd on walk all over you it's
just like we just kind of went into to
it and it just felt like it was flying
and before I knew it it was over and
then we did the second one it was just a
complete
blur and
uh I don't know man it was just one of
it was [__] I still can't believe it
happened and uh I practiced my ass off
for it and like to the point like at
3:00 in the morning last night I woke
up and
uh and the song walk all over you was
like running through my head and my feet
started moving like I was practicing it
I was like wait dude it's over you
already did it you can relax so um
anyway thank you to everybody who came
out thank you to Dean for putting it
together and uh I just I don't know I
can't even tell you what a [__]
thrill that was to play with musicians
of
um of that
caliber uh wait did did I let me make
did I say
everybody um oh mikez on Bas Jesus
Christ I knew I forgot somebody from uh
Allison Chains and he was just like the
nicest [__] guy
ever and uh it was just uh it was
[__] amazing I know it's probably
boring you guys but like you know when
you actually get to do your hobby on a
semipro level like that was pretty
[__] it's pretty great so and then on
top of that like this new [__] that I
was doing I was riffing I was [__]
with the crowd I had such a good time
with them like I was looking like before
I went out on
stage uh Dean was like we got Dave
Lombardo here and he goes uh any Slayer
fans out there and I just see this guy
like you know does this thing and I look
at the guy and it just really made me
feel how old we all know I'm looking at
the guy he like a Slayer fan to me is
just long Browner black hair like
midback and just it's just hanging there
like animal from [__] The Muppets
right and this guy had like a [__]
you know like white in his beard he
looked like you know get off of my lawn
you know like he was at that age and I'm
like looking at the guy going like that
guy was at Slayer concerts in the 80s so
I went out there and I was looking at
the crowd and it was like this [__]
awesome
mly like my generation all of us you
know [__] doing the best we can to
keep the weight off and you just see all
the years a partying and all of that
[__] and I said like this looks like a
support group for people who survived
the80s and I kind of just started
riffing on
that and uh and it was just I just
totally connected with them cuz they
were literally me and then there was
like younger people there who just love
older music which is what I was like so
I just kind of went out there cuz I was
looking at the crowd going like wow man
this this looks like a Florentine crowd
this doesn't look like what my crowd
looks like but but I went out there and
I realized the reason why I love
Florentine in that metal show and I love
him on like Aussie's Boneyard is because
is much he steers harder into that than
I do but I
like uh like him Jim
Brewer Doug Jameson like when I listen
to those guys talking about growing up
it's like the how the level of
similarity and overlap so I didn't
realize like like like that crowd is my
crowd um or not mik proud whatever I
just totally vibed with them and I had
such a [__] great time and um they
laughed at everything I did except I did
this I talked
about uh Lady D dying and they all
groaned on it which I got such a kick
out of I was going like oh yeah the Gaza
Strip stuff is fine I knew it I knew
what I was like being sarcastic saying I
knew that when you know that it was
dangerous in front of a Slayer crowd to
bring
up Princess Diana
dying
um and uh I don't know just because how
great their energy was I tried out all
this new [__] I'm just I'm beyond I'm
chomping at the bit to get back out on
the road which is a [__] amazing
feeling at 55 because um there are days
when I I I wasn't feeling that so this
break has been the perfect thing for me
and uh I'm going to [__] murder when
I get out there and that same energy I
got from the crowd when um I was doing
my jokes I felt it during that first
song and uh you know I got to live that
dream that didn't come true you know I
started off playing drums and jamming
with people and I that I thought that
that's what I was going to do and uh but
I knew that I didn't have I don't
know or maybe I just knew that by the
time I figured it out i' would be 55
[__] years old and like that window
would have closed so just to be able to
pretend doing it for two songs
with [__] people I grew up watching
was was uh was was awesome so with
that and with that we are now college
football season is over congratulations
to the Michigan
Wolverines um and all their DieHard fans
I am a fan but I'm not going to sit here
and act like I I was sitting there
watching every game during the
Appalachian State um years I I talked
about that on the Rich Eisen show um cuz
he's he's like die hard and um you know
I've been watching Michigan for a long
time but during those those years where
it just wasn't happening I'm not going
to lie to you I couldn't [__] watch
so uh for all the the true die hards
that were there when they [__] sucked
and lost to Ohio State which felt like
70 years in a row um
congratulations um amazing
game um fun game to watch it still
drives me nuts when they go forward on
fourth down and I got to be honest with
you like I was like why are they going
for it on fourth down why are they going
for the kill shot in the second quarter
they you got the momentum just kick it
down cough and corner and you know
instead they go for it they don't get it
and then they just concede a field goal
and uh and I think it's stupid to go for
it on fourth down in the second quarter
and then Washington goes for it on
fourth down in the second quarter and
scores a touchdown so rather than it
being 17 to6 all of a sudden it's 17
to10 so it shows you what the [__] I
know
um I don't know if I'm I'm probably
wrong I just an old guy going like
they're not doing it the way they did it
when I was a kid you know I think I'm
just doing that [__] so I'm really
trying hard to
[__] you know not [__] about the
same [__] [__] so I'm kind of over
that and uh but I really like the
Washington Huskies and uh their
quarterback and their wide receiver that
kid Roma however you say his last name
man he just looks like you
know I mean he was wide open a lot it's
just Michigan was getting so much
pressure on that
quarterback um and then came up with two
big
interceptions
um you know Jesus Christ [__] unreal
so anyway that's all I got I don't have
any advertising people so uh I don't
know what I'm going to be hanging out
with my kids uh this weekend you know
going to take him up uh I don't know I
don't know where we're going to go go
we're thinking of going away this
weekend I don't know what
um you know I got my ass in shape
finally I've been doing three days on
one day off at the [__] gym I'm
feeling strong again my shoulders are
all right but I'm also kind of like you
know not as strong as I used to be
because I'm [__] old so I just got to
watch out for that [__] um now my
[__] knee's talking to me it never
ends so uh anyway with that uh oh and
shout out to Joe Koy fellow standup
comedian you know uh Jesus Christ
everybody jumping all over that guy like
I I I'll tell you right now I would not
want to do that [__] gig only getting
10 days and uh you know that's
um that is a uh that's a tough gig
so I only worked with that guy I think
one time on the
road and I thought he was ridiculously
talented and he [__] murdered and he
also clo I want to know he went on
second to last and I'm not going to say
who the person after uh really had to
work and it was a big comic so
um that guy yeah I think a lot of people
got a bad p uh wrong perception of that
guy man you
know
um Jesus
Christ that looked like a [__]
corporate gig you
know one of those [__] it's like
we've all we've all had that that gig
it's just wasn't on TV so uh yeah
whatever [__] Shake It Off Move On
[__] him um that's it all right that's
the podcast for the for uh this Thursday
then we have a bonus episode of the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast have a great
weekend your [__] and uh let's enjoy
some NFL playoffs playoffs all right
I'll see you
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for
Monday January 11th 2016 what's going on
how are you how's it going I'm in a
great [__] mood I don't know why you
know what I haven't boozed in like
[__] I don't know what it's been I
don't know 9 10 days or something like
that I did have a sip of wine last night
but I don't really consider that boozing
you know the way I go after
it
um my wife so you know something it's
funny when I when I stop drinking my
wife always tries to get me back to
drinking not to get drunk or anything
she just is like you're so [__] you
know I drive her so [__] nuts that I
I just think
sometimes you know if she wasn't such a
good person I think she would try and
like drug me every night like around
supper right make a little dinner be
like how is that honey oh look at you
you look sleepy like I have no idea like
she just put some [__] in my food not to
like kill me just to sort of sedate me
um but uh anyways but I haven't drank in
like 10 days or something W that really
made my head go somewhere like wow
that's kind of [__] up she does that
um but yeah I haven't drank in like 10
days I
uh I'm feeling good and and so what
happens is then I slowly you know I
start to eat better I'm starting my day
off with the old uh from the old country
thing you know little [__] uh water
at room
temperature which should make you gag if
you're any kind of a [__] human being
but uh you get used to it with some
lemon and then a little cayenne pepper
in it and then I take uh let that settle
in me then I get a couple scoops of uh
Greek yogurt the all natural stuff that
actually kind of tastes like sour cream
and the first time I I ate it I was like
this is the worst [__] I've ever tasted
tasted because I was used to the uh the
crack baby yogurt that I've been eating
my whole life that has like [__] 40
bags of sugar in it you know when you
eat yogurt you're like
yeah I mean the amount of sugar that's
in [__] regular yogurt you am you
should [__] snort it I mean it's
literally like I mean I'm aot I still
[__] love it but uh the Greek [__]
took me a minute and now I'm actually uh
I like it man if I drink this [__] and
just have a couple scoops of that it
kind of fills me up
and um that's kind of the big thing is
you become an old [__] like me it's just
just somehow getting the hunger to go
away without doing damage to yourself
you know and then walking around and
burning a few calories before you go to
the next one you know and I know this
Bunch you know hopefully some younger
listeners listening to this judging me
go list is this old fart talking about
[__] lemon water cayenne pepper and
[__] Greek yogurt well you know
something if you're lucky enough you'll
live long enough if we don't [__] up
something or something bad doesn't
happen to you uh you know to get to my
age and you know it's good to start
healthy habits now [__] shut up Bill
what are you the [__] first lady you
know what I'm doing right I'm doing [__]
that like a first lady does right now
I'm actually let's get in shape
kids how about you go outside for 10
minutes a day and you just do some
jumping
checks can you [__] believe that that
you got to tell kids to go out and
play you know that's how [__] insane
video games have got I mean if I made
video games and I actually saw Michelle
Obama on TV begging kids to try to not
have their first cardiac incident by the
time they're in the third grade I mean I
I would tear up and just be like I did
it you know I am so [__] great at my
job I've made children stop playing
outside you know do you think there's
like the Alec Baldwin of the video game
industry you know from Glen Gary Glenn
Ross coming in just screaming at
him you know me kids I cause to have a
heart attack seven [__] you right just
screaming at
him trying to get him
to we haven't done our [__] jobs till
every kid has a [__] pacemaker by the
seventh
grade um
I don't know anyway yeah so I'm trying
to get back in shape so uh I've been
stoned sober so yesterday I got my uh my
my first massage in like I don't know
like two years whenever I get a massage
afterwards I always think like I got to
start doing this man this is great for
an old fart like me you know and then
you come home you crush the waters you
get all the toxins out of you or
whatever yoga [__] they tell you to do
and
um but I know this always happens I'm
like I'm [__] do this you know what
once once a month I'm going to go down
there you know [__] you haven't work
out my [__] back like my whole I
don't know what's like I have a little
curvature of the spine and the lady's
like where are the problem areas right
and of course your brain always goes my
dick but you know it's illegal
Place yeah you seem to be having a uh
problem in the uh Central pelvic area on
the frontal lobe um I'm like like I
never even noticed either I was like uh
my right shoulder my right forearm and
my right foot and I was just like wow
how [__] up is my right side and then
I realized all of them all of those
injuries I got from playing
drums you know my right forearm from
[__] holding the stick
wrong I don't know what I'm doing with
my shoulders probably after I [__] up
another fill looking at the bass player
and shrugging like I'm sorry I mean I
tried to get back on one right and then
my foot I [__] that up years ago
trying to get my base drum as fast as
John Bonhams you know which I never even
remotely achieved I just have the
lifetime pain you know every time I take
a step I'm always reminded of what a
wonderful drummer John bonam is um so
anyways uh I did that um with the lovely
Nia that's always a good thing to do you
know you go in there with your wife then
you don't feel like a dirt bag cuz
anytime I go to get a massage I always
feel like a dirt bag there's just no way
not to feel like a [__] complete
piece of [__] when you walk in they're
like yeah I want you to
I want you to work out the Kinks there
sweetheart you know what I
mean um wait a minute what am I talking
about I got a massage in [__]
uh
Milwaukee no I didn't no I didn't that
was Este
steam that was Este steam that's right
oh that's right that's right yeah I
guess I haven't in like two [__]
years and they always do the same thing
when they when they put my hands on my
back they just go wow
wow do you have a lot of stress has it
been a while it's like I
yeah your back feels like
gravel so anyways uh we did that and
then we came home and um we made uh
Mario Batali's uh lasagna
bologan and uh it was [__] delicious
uh homemade past homemade pasta things
and all that I got to get my homemade
pasta game up I try to make the spin
pasta and this the pasta was definitely
green but you could still see the chunks
of uh spinach in there you know what I
mean so what does that mean did I not
need the dough enough was uh cuz it was
frozen spinach like it said to be you
like the the the recipe said to be am I
saying that right like the recipe
said said to be what the [__] does that
mean like the re said it should be I
think that's what I was trying to say
but um you know I dried it
out and maybe I just didn't dice it up
enough I have no idea but um I'm
actually psyched that uh the consistency
though I can get that down I might have
needed it needed to need it a little bit
more I don't know is there any
uh higher qualified people out there
that could help me out on how to make uh
the right spinach pasta cuz I watched
some videos and I still [__] the thing
up but anyway so we did all of that and
meanwhile I was watching like the
playoff games playoffs
and um [__] great games this weekend
Heartbreakers but just
[__] just great games with also that
that creeping sadness that I always have
when the playoffs are here that it's
just like did another regular season go
by that [__]
fast god damn it it's it's going to be
over it's another month it's going to be
[__] over this time next month this
I'm not even going to say because it's
going to be too [__]
depressing
um
however I have gotten totally into the
Celtics and NBA hoop with my Bruins so I
mean I got a game almost every night
sometimes too but anyways so uh let's go
through them let's go through them as
every [__] douche who doesn't like
sports is going to roll their eyes just
fast forward like [__] 40 minutes and
you'll be safe um the first one I saw I
think I W I taped all of them um so I
watched them at weird times I watched uh
the second half of the original Texans
the Kansas City chief
just absolutely dominating the uh the
new Texans and I actually tweeted that
out to on uh on
Twitter um and I actually got a ton of
[__] for it people like oh what are you
trying to show off your sports knowledge
it's like no I like sharing it I love
when people do stuff like I'm a sports
nerd okay I'm not acting like I played
at a professional level I just love that
[__] so I'm going to take you through it
for those of you who didn't know that
the chiefs were originally called the
Texans they actually played in Dallas
Texas um when the AFL first started and
when the AFL first came out the NFL the
established League publicly laughed at
them and said these guys are crazy then
this will never work hahaa whatever you
know are you nervous no we're not
nervous at all we're just going to do
you know the American people know where
the quality football is at right that's
what they said publicly and then behind
the scenes as much as they may or may
have not believed that they then hedged
their
bets and they wanted to try to
um sabotage the AFL as much as they
could before it even got
started so the AFL how many [__]
teams did they have they had the Boston
Patriots the Buffalo Bills the New York
[Music]
Titans uh the Dallas Texans the
Minnesota Vikings and I'll get back to
that before you say that I'm wrong on
that they had the Minnesota
Vikings hey I used to know this by
heart Denver Broncos Oakland
Raiders San Diego Chargers I'm sorry the
Los Angeles
Chargers and
uh Dolphins weren't in it Bengals
weren't in it who the [__] else is left
Bears Lions yeah something like that I I
probably forgot a team or two and um
so the owner with the most money was
Lamar Lundy I believe that was his name
I didn't look the [__] up again but I I
read this whole book on it Lamar Lundy
and he was the wealthiest of all owners
so basically this guy could hold out the
longest in this new crazy Venture all
right so they well how they attacked the
[__] AFL they did it on two different
levels the Dallas Texans were owned by
Lamar londy the most wealthiest of all
the owners so what they the NFL did was
they awarded Dallas a team which became
the Dallas Cowboys so for a season or
two I forget I didn't look it up as I
said they you could either go see the
Dallas Cowboys or the Dallas Texans now
the Dallas Cowboys as much as they were
an expansion franchise you could go down
and watch them get the [__] kicked out
of them you know by Johnny United Jim
Brown or or you know Frank gford or all
these guys you know all these Legends
the [__] Green Bay Packers would come
to town you get to see Vince Lombardi
and the the the early days of the Packer
sweep you could see all this
professional level Talent or you could
go across town and go see the Dallas
Texans a bunch of nobody's playing a
bunch of nobodies because they weren't
established yet so obviously that
completely um that's a no-brainer as a
sports fan you're going to go see the
NFL team and go see all these stars that
you've been watching on TV so uh that
completely [__] them and they had to
move to Kansas City and they became the
Chiefs they kept their colors though but
they were originally called the Texans
but they gave up the name and then the
Minnesota
Vikings which I did not know I didn't
know any of this [__] till I read the
book the Minnesota Vikings were
originally going to be an AFL team so
what the NFL did was not only award
Dallas a team they
also went to the owners of the Minnesota
Vikings and said hey do you want to just
join the NFL and not be part of the AFL
come on we're an established league and
of course they said hey [__] you guys
and your new Venture we're going to
[__] [__] the whole going against the
NFL we're going to join them so that's
what they did they uh they opened a
franchise across town from the
wealthiest owner and then they stole one
of their teams that that was their two
moves as they publicly laughed at the
AFL so there you go there's a little
[__] uh little little history from
all freckles um but haven't said that
you know maybe they got them back but I
guess they'd have to beat the [__]
Cowboys and they're also part of the NFL
so uh congratulations to the Chiefs and
evidently they're playing the Patriots
is what I got from some of the tweets
and uh I am not a comfortable Patriot
fan no Patriot fan who's been watching
the Patriots is you know we had a lot of
losses towards the end of the year um
I'm hoping you know we're going to get
some help back on our offensive line um
either way it's going to be even if we
were healthy it it would have been a
brutal day cuz uh you know Andy Reid is
no slouch as much as a guy gets a ton of
[__] I mean the guy's been to a bunch of
uh NFC championship games and [__] like
that he has been there before but you
know you do need the players you do need
the ownership you need all of that type
of [__] to try to uh to try to succeed
so uh congratulations to them and um I
am by no means comfortable with next
week um and you know also you know the
Chiefs beat the Seattle Seahawks as far
as being the loudest fans at one point
and they did it in that old ass Stadium
rather than the uh the stadium the
Seahawks fans have that helps him out
and contains the
sound I'm such a [__] but it's true
um and uh yeah so speaking of the
Vikings and the Bengals my condolences
to fans of both teams I've been there
fortunately have not been there in a
long time I guess the Giants losses but
I can't whine as a fan with all the
other [__] that was going on but uh
Jesus [__] Christ what the [__] was
that guy doing after he picked off the
ball walking up to the tunnel already
celebrating I thought [__] athletes
were were
superstitious the [__] are you
doing right there right I that's [__]
unbelievable to me and then he's [__]
sitting there he probably already took
his goddamn cleats off and then the very
next play what was it two plays in they
fumble the [__] ball I had to watched
this part of the game on Highlights cuz
I tape the game and for the one time I
don't do the extended [__] record
this [__] happens and uh um probably had
to put his cleats on run back out on the
field I think he was so [__]
frustrated because he still had
champagne you know coursing through his
veins he was already mentally the next
week that he goes into was the same guy
right goes in and [__] knocks out
that
player
unfuckingbelievable hey Steeler fans how
many of you shut the game off after the
interception huh not cuz you're a fair
weather fan just because you couldn't
stomach to watch the Bengal fans jumping
up and down and having some Joy you know
I I'd forgive you if you did that I'd
forgive you if you walked away you know
or if you already started celebrating
and you turned your big [__] sausage
eating back to the [__] TV and you're
already
doing who do we got next week doing all
that [__] [__]
brutal and uh the Vikings I won't even I
don't even can you explain to me how you
place kicker had the laces facing your
kicker twice in one [__] game and a
playoff
game that's un [__] I've never I you
never see the laces
in right I never even knew about I'm not
going to lie to you I didn't never even
knew about laces out since [__] Ace
Ventura that's when I learned about it
or is it Ace Ventura
um Jesus [__] I mean I watched the
replay of that game and I went on
Twitter beforehand and I and I found out
the Vikings won which a [__] suck but
I was in the middle of you know trying
to make spinach pasta which was well
beyond my cooking abilities so you know
I was a little [__] uh got a little
sideways there for a minute and
um I was thinking like what the [__] he
must make this field
goal and then Seattle just has a
ridiculous kickoff return and then
they're able to kick it or maybe they
they score a touchdown or maybe a
defensive back falls down I I no idea
that he was going to [__] lose oh my
God [__]
brutal but you know what every
championship team you got to have a
little bit of luck the first [__]
Super Bowl the Patriots won we had the
Tuck Rule which was a [__]
rule everybody blames Tom Brady it was a
blame the officials oh no the the rule
Rules Committee for coming up with that
weird one CU I say to this day that's a
[__] fumble that's a fumble the way
sugar bear Hamilton did not interfere
with Ken ster the year the [__]
Raiders won it in Super Bowl 11 so
anybody in Oakland put your [__]
Hanes away cuz I don't want to hear you
crying about it that was payback for
Super Bowl uh not Super Bowl 11 the
[__] playoffs playoffs in uh
77 when sugar bear Hamilton was already
in the air jumping at Ken Stabler and
and then he lets the ball go and they
called roughing the passer and back then
it wasn't a 15 yard penalty it it they
put the ball where the guy threw it and
and it was the end of the game and he
threw a 50 yard [__]
prayer Ray Hamilton's already in the
[__] air lands on Ken Stabler they
call roughing the passer and they took
the ball from like the 50 and put it on
the [__] one-in line and then the
Raiders went and won the [__] game so
I don't want to hear anything about it
but I am man enough to say that the Tuck
Rule is [__] horseshit and uh I think
it's a fumble you know but I'm not
expecting that level of maturity from
Raider fans you know aan base that goes
to the game you know dressed with um you
know spikes on your shoulder pads that
have been checked by security to make
sure that they're totally safe as you
make a I'm not safe angry
face um you know something that does bug
me I can't stand when they [__]
um when people get upset that Hollywood
has the audacity have Awards to have
award shows and they always talk about
the self- congratulatory night uh
um like what business doesn't have an
award show it's just not [__]
televised you know if you [__] drill
for oil you know they have the best of
you know BP and all them they have their
[__] yearly [__] Christmas party
you know best regional
manager goes to CLM cenfield out of
[__] Misha CLM I'm paying for that
call girl tonight just kidding is his
wife here you know they do and they give
a little [__] trophy they have
salesman of the month [__] you work at
McDonald's you can get employee of the
month you know you know they have
franchise of the year you join the
[__] Cub Scouts you tie your [__]
shoes they give you a little badge to
sew on your [__] shirt
right why isn't Hollywood allowed to
have that little
[__]
evening what is it huh what is it that
bugs
you that there's a bunch of a hot famous
ass
there oh Jesus I'm
sorry you know what I want to see I want
to see somebody go out there and defend
Bill Cosby on an award show dead serious
and just [__] hold it and never let
anybody in on the joke and then try to
continue hosting and do it in the
monolo let's see if they ask you
back all right I'm done being a [__] um
Pats vers Kansas City no I'm not this is
what I want to [__] read here I want
to read uh the live reads advertising
all right you know it be great as even
if you even if you you know have a 9
to-5 regular job if you start off with a
decent breakfast you bring your [__]
lunch and then you order Blue Apron at
night and you all know did I say y'all
y'all you all know what I'm talking
about um dinner is what [__] your diet
at least for me cuz I can eat well the
whole [__] day whole day I'm doing
good I'm doing good and then by [__]
4:00 I'm like I want some [__] potato
chips you I want some ice cream you know
if you can just [__] call these [__]
and have them deliver a 500 700 meal and
you just [__] eat the [__] right then
you're done drink waters for the rest of
the night have a little celery already
cut up you know throw a spoonful of
peanut butter in there you know it's
going to melt
off unless you have you know I don't
know some built-in excuse you know like
a lot of overweight people do oh my
metabolism is really slow yeah yeah that
8,000 calories a [__] day dude oh you
know we only have four this week so why
don't I do two and two let's do that all
right let's get back to the thing here
um all right uh
oh today as I'm rushing through this
[__]
podcast um I'm having somebody coming
over looking at my garage today I even
have to whisper this [__] I somehow talk
my
wife into uh you know allowing me to
have just have somebody come over and
take a look at the garage I know I did
that a couple months back but then I got
busy but now I I got the person coming
back again and uh I'm actually using
her skills you know that she does with
me that's how I ended up with the dog
like we're not getting this dog we're
just were uh fostering the dog for a
couple days cuz she knew that I'd fall
in love with the [__] dog and then
that would be it so it's kind of like
when you first start start dating a
woman um you know and she wants a
relationship when she comes over to your
apartment what she starts to do is she
leaves [__] there cuz it gives her an
excuse to come back I mean that's
[__] nuts right like they're thinking
that far ahead all you're sitting there
it's like look at those tits what the
[__] right that's all you're thinking
and they're sitting there plotting you
know what I mean it's like you're some
[__] head coach that has no game plan
and she's across the field like [__]
Bill Walsh calling the first 25 plays of
the game right oh I love A Football Life
there's a nice reference to you
um so you know what's [__] hilarious
and speaking of which the Patrice O'Neal
benefit's coming up once again I'll tell
you a quick Patrice story
um he was so [__] brilliant
that I remember he was dating this woman
and you know or whatever seeing her and
she started leaving [__] around his
house and I I just had brought that up I
go yeah you know I dated this woman you
know she left this [__] here and she
left that it's like what the [__] you
know I only see her like you know once
every two weeks she just has [__] there
so for 2 weeks I keep looking at her
[__] brush or the shampoo she left or
whatever and it just I keep thinking
about her and it's annoying
me and Patrice just goes he goes so
throw it
out I go what he goes throw it
out I go I can't throw out a brush he
goes I would I go get the [__] out of he
goes yeah he goes I did that he told me
a story where there was a woman he was
messing around with and she left these
toiletries and a little bag of like you
know makeup and brush and all that and
he he [__] threw it
out and then she came back like a week
and a half
later and she goes to go in the bathroom
she's like uh she's like hey what did
you do with my uh my
stuff he goes and he just plays dumb he
goes what stuff she goes I left shampoo
here I had a little makeup bag he goes
oh I was your yeah he goes yeah I threw
it out
and she was like literally beside
herself but actually on some level
respected
him for like [__] realizing what she
was
doing and then also I think because that
early on he clearly let her know in a
very funny [__] way that he wasn't
looking for a relationship and uh that
she was able to relax and kind of be
thinking oh we're just [__]
all right I wanted a little more he
doesn't at least but he let her know so
[__] early on that it didn't really
hurt you know does that make sense I
mean I maybe I'm speaking for her
but I guess I am but whatever either way
it was [__] funny oh Jesus was that
the [__]
worst I literally just jumped out of the
plane and pulled a [__] rip CT on
that story sorry it's been a while it's
been a while since I told that story
hasn't it or have I told it before I
don't [__] know so anyway so I'm kind of
using
um my the same [__] tricks that my
wife used that got me the dog I'm using
with her because um we're going to like
hey why am I Whispering here like she
can't just listen to the [__]
podcast [__] sometimes like how dumb
I am it just really [__] so anyways
what I want to
do is I have this old school [__] you
know my house is built in 1923 so the
the garage whenever it was [__] built
was built
um to house like a [__] Model T Ford
kind of car and those things were those
things you sat inside the [__] wheel
wells you know what I mean if you if you
look at old
cars um you know how the fenders used to
flare out and then there was just the
engine and you know you sat like
literally like right
behind basically where you you sat I
can't I don't know if I'm explaining
correctly you know what I mean you're
sitting inside the [__] wheel wheel
wells right not like literally in them
but as far as like the line down the
side of the car right like if you stuck
your head out and you didn't have any
fenders on it you'd be looking at the
[__] tire right as opposed to you
know the [__]
road I know all you guys know what I'm
talking about um it also goes to show
you like how [__] fat and and and big
people have gotten you know what I mean
two things if you ever go to Mount
Vernon and you go to Thomas Jefferson's
house and you have to duck underneath
the [__]
uh the
uh the [__] do you call them the door
frames you see how much taller people
are and then when you look at those old
[__]
cars the fact that two adults could sit
side by side like that and it wouldn't
be they probably won't even touching
each other you know so anyways what I'm
trying to say is that my uh my garage is
long and skinny and it's like high up
you
know and uh and then it kind of flares
out at the back as it kind of wraps
around the back of the house a little
bit so what I want to do the the front
part is long enough for me to squeeze my
truck in
there um but then in the back what I
want to do is I want to turn that into
like a little gym which my wife is all
for and then I'm also pitching that I
build maybe a little drum room I could
actually I got this drum kit that I
bought that I have in cases that if I
want to play it I have to throw it in
the truck and drive it down to a studio
I'm thinking of making build like a room
within a room which will add no value to
the house unless I someday sell it to
another [__] drummer who also
Whispers on his own [__] podcast like
his wife can't hear it [__] I'm still
Whispering well you know why you know
why because the guy's coming in like a
half hour and my wife is asleep
downstairs if she hears me yelling about
it I might have to have this argument
sooner than I'm prepared to have it so
um that is the game plan and like a
couple months back I bought those atomic
holds um
you know all those things like that that
American Ninja [__] so down downstairs
in the garage I want to just have those
hanging from the ceiling so I can do all
that grip strength [__] that I want to
get better at by the way I [__]
started working out for the first time
in forever and I went to do go do
pull-ups holy
[__] I literally felt like I was like do
I have sandbags in my pockets what the
[__] going on I did six good ones and
whimpered through the last four I always
try to do 10 I can't even [__] do it
it's pathetic um
so that's like the big exciting thing in
my life right now and I gotta kind of
get this thing
going um before my wife wakes up and
finds something
else to do in the house you know maybe I
don't know so anyways by the way people
I'm doing a gig in uh
Vancouver I'm doing a gig in Vancouver
uh Canada this Sunday night a last
second one that was added because I left
my January open because I'm still
waiting to hear about a uh season 2 we
uh meet with Netflix this week to pitch
them our ideas for season 2
uh so if you've already watched fers for
family I thank you so much because
you've gotten me to at least getting the
meeting so we'll see uh we will see what
happens um with that and um so I hadn't
booked
anything um in January so now we're
having some last second gigs um coming
up I'm going to do a gig in Vancouver
this Sunday and then I'm going to do a
couple dates one or two dates I think
right before the Patrice O'Neal
benefit um in the tri-state area we're
still um trying to [__] iron those
things
out as we speak Jesus Christ Bill spit
it out all right let's get to the uh the
questions of this
week um all right
inbox inbox inbox where's the content
here's the no I had it on the other page
what am I doing oh there we go all right
Bill Patriots first Kansas City hello
there Mr Burr how's it going you
freckled [__] there how are you uh hope
your holidays were just peachy same to
Cleo and Nia uh today I just wanted to
hear your honest and objective thoughts
about the matchup between your Pats and
my Chiefs this weekend I was just
listening to your podcast from 12 7:15
where you said casc won't win
[__] somebody tweeted me that I said
that I talk so much trash I don't even
remember saying saying that uh and I'm
content that you may eat those words
this week oh absolutely oh I absolutely
might eat those words this week uh but
having SE I think I meant well Casey
won't win [__] you're not going to win
the Super Bowl that's what I mean my
pick is uh the Seattle Seahawks which is
not really a
uh is not really a a genius pick by any
stretch of the means they've been there
too [__] years in a row
um I mean didn't they win yesterday
without Marshon Lynch I was running back
and forth trying to make lasagna noodles
uh as far as I know I didn't see Marshon
Lynch in there my wife was also clicking
back and forth to like the [__]
Golden Globes so um I just know that
they uh no no wait that was that was the
earlier one dude you know yesterday I
watched I watched [__] Ohio State
Indiana I watched two playoff football
games and I watched half of a Celtic
game and fell asleep it was [__]
ridiculous so I'm I'm trying to remember
what the [__] I saw this weekend but um
no I don't think it's going to be an
easy uh listen I got to tell you this if
we were [__] healthy we would kick
the [__] out of you all right if we
actually had an offensive line and
Edelman was back and am andola was back
we had a [__] running game and we if
we were healthy this is no [__]
contest at home you know it and I know
it right now Brady is driving a [__]
rental car so you might go in there and
beat us and then you're going to get
[__] excited and loud and then you
know what I don't know you know why
would I root against you guys hey you
know what you guys hey you guys haven't
won since what
1970 right what was that
uh what was that [__] Hank stram
call power trap cross 57 power trap
cross what the [__] was that thing
called I don't remember you guys hav an
uh when you beat the [__]
Vikings Jesus Christ going way back
you beat the AFL team that [__] sold
out maybe that's why they're cursed
maybe that's why they've lost what do
they lose three three four Super Bowls
three Super Bowls right they lost to the
[__]
Chiefs they lost to the
Packers they lost to the Dolphins and
they lost to the Steelers is that right
wait the Dolphins lost to the
Cowboys then
they beat the Vikings and they beat the
Redskins that's right Chiefs beat the
Vikings Green Bay
beat the
Chiefs they didn't beat the Raiders did
they they beat the Vikings right no the
Vikings would have been in the NFL by
then I don't [__] whatever you lost
like [__] three of them maybe because
you you didn't stick with the AFL
guys does that make any sense whatever
good luck to the Chiefs this week uh
good luck to the Patriots obviously my
heart is with the Patriots but uh you
know I don't know I didn't like like
that Dolphins game where every time
Brady the few times he went back to pass
there was just somebody right in his
grill every [__] time um but whatever
the end of the [__] day we have the
greatest [__] quarterback and coach
of all [__] time so go [__] yourself
I think we're going to beat you all
right it'd be no fun if I just said good
luck to you guys so [__] you guys you
don't stand a chance there now if you
beat me you got something to talk about
then he can Trash me and I can fill out
a [__] hour next week on the podcast
um all right drive to school oh by the
way
Alabama the dream Ends Tonight Alabama
Clemson I have no I don't know [__]
about either team I was so [__] busy
in the fall I didn't get to watch any of
it but of course
um I I wouldn't care if Alabama won but
Clemson hasn't won in a while so I'd
love to see them win however if If
Alabama wins it just makes the Cleveland
Browns futility even funnier to me
because the dumbest [__] move ever do
you realize that they had Bill bich and
Nick Sabin coaching their team and they
fired
them the the [__] Paul Brown Vince
Lombardi of the modern day NFL and the
Paul Brown Bear Bryant Vince
Lombardi of NCAA division one football
they had them both coaching
together and they fired him so if
Alabama as a Cleveland Brown fan you
have to be
rooting for Clemson you just have to you
guys have had enough [__] pain right
who knows maybe LeBron can get you over
the hump this year you know uh I always
root for Cleveland like I said I I have
relatives you know family that grew up
out there and all that type of [__] I uh
I actually love Cleveland so um however
I also love a good joke so If Alabama
wins ton it'll still be funny anyways
continue on drive to school hey Bill
I've been a fan of yours since the O
Anda days in Chappelle Show somewhere
along the line I had a kid and he's old
enough to listen to some of your podcast
uh I listen to it with him on the drive
to school I listen to the whole episode
before beforehand and cut out any of the
stuff that is a bit heavy or
sexual um Jesus you're [__] great dad
when you start editing their content you
know look at you you're a regular tip of
uh not because I'm Sheltering him but
because he and I don't need don't need
share certain podcast moments when you
talk of jizz and in some skank before
8:00 a.m. exactly let the kid have a
childhood uh trying to keep it light and
positive with the exception of the funny
negative anyways I wanted to tell you
that it's the best thing we got going we
listened to about 15 minutes a day it
puts him and I in a laughing mood which
he needs school is a lot of work these
days and and he always got a ton of
homework and projects and his dragging
in the morning this wakes him up
sometimes we pause and talk about
certain things or all explain certain
stuff to him about politics Sports Etc
yeah in other words correct the dumb
[__] that I said all that father son
stuff uh thanks for the parental assist
Ah that's great who would ever thought
my ignorance could be hot
Waring um anyways uh I'm already
regretting [__] making fun of Ricky
jvas why did I do that [__] but you know
I mean he's making fun of everybody on
the show it's only fair
right they're showing up with [__]
acceptance speeches and he's got all
those [__] zingers that him and his
writing staff wrote it's only fair
that's why I like Mel Gibson Mel Gibson
gave him [__] back I don't understand
why people just go out smiling they
should [__] trash
him uh vasectomy uh dear bill I don't
want to get a
vasectomy I just don't my wife and
anyone else who ch times in on the
subject started trying to break down
positives and point out the lack of
negatives ever just not want something I
just don't want one can you believe this
or you with everyone else that it must
be rooted in some fear Etc [__] that
dude [__] that are you [__] kidding
me do you think you could [__] tell a
woman what the [__] to do with her body
for two seconds before she just said
you're a you're a chauvinistic
[__] yeah dude [__] that [__] that all
day long that's your [__] dick and
balls all right not that they [__] with
your dick if you don't [__] want them
to go in there and snip snip whatever
the [__] I've even looked up the
operation I still don't get it I don't
get
it nothing comes out so does it stop
your ability to make
jizz do they put an utter down there
where you got to milk the jizz out oh
that's disgusting I I I don't get I
don't get what happens but [__]
that [__] that
[__] that just just sit down with your
wife say listen I don't want to do that
and she'll be like why why not you're
just a you're just fear-based it's like
no it isn't I don't want to be walking
around and it like dude you know what
that's like you're like a muscle car and
they want to rip the engine out and put
a [__] V6 in there [__] you and keep
your Shelby badge on the side of your
car and every day in the morning you
wake
up standing there looking at yourself
after you get out of the shower and
knowing that it's a
lie [__] that dude [__] you keep the
bullets in that gun all right she can't
handle it you know I you know what is
she going to do to
you huh she going to hold you down and
make while someone else does it just
yeah you don't want one dude you don't
want one to the level you're reaching
out to a [__]
podcast okay do you understand I would
even use that in your argument just be
like but don't play this audio though I
would just say
listen I so do not want to do this that
I actually wrote into a podcast to get
advice that's how much I don't want to
do this and then she'll just be like
well maybe we need to go talk to
somebody about it which means she's
going to set up an appointment with
somebody who agrees with
her all right cuz she's going to set up
the appointment going listen my husb
usand needs to get a vasectomy he's very
nervous he says he doesn't want to get
it but I it's going to be the best for
us and she's going to totally set the
[__] table it's like those dumb [__]
that go on Dr
Phil you ever see those sad sacks that
go on that [__] show with their wife
like they have a [__]
Prayer Dr Phil's audience is women so
he's going to have to side with the
woman every [__] time even if he you
know he's going to try to you know hide
his hand and give her a little bit of
[__] but at the end of the day he's
going to be looking at you going you
need to get your balls
snipped right he's going to come at you
like that while he sits there you know
with his junk still [__] working you
know he's got a giant [__] unit
doesn't he that big [__] goof that
big bald goof walking down the hall you
know he's got a [__] giant [__]
unit big great great dane
balls I don't know why I think he's got
a [__] giant unit he does he's just
like he's just the way he talks he's
just God always gives them big
dicks it just I don't know what it is
um this giant size 16 brown wooden wing
tips just sitting across from you this
got to be the worst [__] show ever to
be on oh my God I never thought about Dr
Phil's junk before you see that it takes
somebody to [__] bring up a vasectomy
you'll never be able to think about him
again May and my big dick say you need
to listen to your
wife all right jumping out of a
plane hey Bill where are you at on
jumping out of a
plane uh if you're a chicken [__]
American I'm a Brit how much money would
it take you to
jump uh I got a bet with my
mate that you hate heights and it take
$500,000 don't change your answer to be
contrary to what I just guessed keep it
fair good sir thanks ah Jesus another
arrogant
Brit these guys think they're [__]
Geniuses
um I've already done it you [__]
idiot and I paid someone to do it I paid
I went to uh in peil Massachusetts when
I was 19 years years old and I didn't do
a tandem jump either I did a static line
jump I've told this story on the podcast
sir if you're a little bit um more up on
it uh and also I have a pilot's license
I fly
helicopters so if I was afraid of
heights I mean I'm afraid of heights
look if I don't have a parachute on my
back and I'm not in a in a
uh in a vehicle that's designed to fly
then yes I'm afraid of heights like I
don't like
uh you know like if you like one time I
watched a YouTube video and they just
showed these guys that had to climb up
to the top of this [__]
building and
then no not climbed to well they took
the elevator who's getting ho they they
they were on the roof and it was already
on the [__] roof this building was so
[__] high up and you know the wind up
there must be ridiculous I would
literally just lay down in the fetal
position and crawl back to the [__]
door that leads to the stairwell reach
up to the
handle and [__] go back down but this
this
dude
um then climbs the [__] the the the
whatever the the the radio tower or
whatever and it just keeps getting
higher and higher and higher and and the
tower gets smaller and smaller and
smaller and he's hooking and unhooking
his safety line I literally I I couldn't
I mean obviously the guy lived because
it's his GoPro on his helmet and I've
never been so [__] unsettled watching
something in my life okay then I would
hate heights but I think at that point
everybody hates Heights but um yeah when
I was 19 years
old I went to uh this place uh in peppol
Massachusetts which I don't think exists
anymore there might still be an airport
there and they had a uh a
school and uh you I did the static line
jump if you've ever seen that movie uh
Fandango one of Kevin Cosner's earlier
ones where the dude from uh Breakfast
Club uh Jud Nelson his character jumps
out um that's exactly what I did and I
remember when we went up the command was
sit in the door get out and then he
slapped you on the shoulder and said go
and
uh I remember when he said sit in the
door I thought he was saying close the
door so I was reaching up I'm sitting
down reaching up trying to close the
door and he had this big smile on his
face like he thought I was chickening
out I feel like I just told this story
on the
podcast and then I finally realized he
was saying sit in the door so you sit in
the door and basically it's one of those
planes where the the wing is above the
aircraft you know what I mean it's on
top of the aircraft as opposed to below
which actually gives you a much better
sight I would think um as far as if you
wanted to look down um and then there's
the support that goes to the side of the
plane so and then right above one of the
landing Wheels the wheels don't retract
on this plane they had uh welded a
little
step
so you sat in the [__]
door and uh I forget how high we were I
want to say we were only like 1,500 we
weren't that high up because your shoot
immediately comes
out um
so you sat you sit in the door then he
goes get out and then what you do is you
reach out and you grab that support beam
from the wing and you hold on to that
while one of your feet is uh is standing
on that little step thing and then
basically what you do is I'm literally
acting this out so I can remember is you
then basically you you bend your arms
and you bring your chest like flush with
the support beam and then the the the
foot that's dangling you put it straight
out behind you it's almost like a yoga
pose so we sit in the door get out and
then he slaps your shoulder and he goes
go and you let go and then you you Arch
you Arc right Arc one Arc 1000 2 1000 3
1000 look if nothing look reach pull and
when you're looking you're looking over
your your shoulder to see if your shoot
came out and then if nothing you look
down at the
handle reach pull it cuz for some reason
they say if you don't look down you
might be flailing because you're
panicking cuz it's the first time you
jumped and the shoot didn't come
out sorry cayenne
pepper hang on a
second so
anyways I get
out he goes go I let go and instead of
arching I I don't know what I did I just
reached for something all I know is I
started doing front front flips at as my
shoot was coming out and I felt it go by
my leg the inside of my leg I felt it go
by my leg I felt something hit that and
I was immediately thinking oh my God I'm
going to roll right up in this [__]
thing like you know when you put bacon
on
shrimp and uh the second I had that
thought like the Shute already had come
out and by the grace of God I didn't get
tangled up I think about that sometimes
like how easily I could have [__]
died um and then boom your shoe comes
out and when your shoe comes out you
don't even feel like you're falling
because there's nothing going past you
cuz you're above the tree line and all
that so you just feel like you're just
sort of suspended in the
air and uh there was a radio and this
lady just talked you in she say pull the
left toggle and you had to pull it all
the way down to your knee cuz I remember
there was this this big girl in the
class and she couldn't get it around her
hips and uh she landed across the street
in a pile of loom and uh dislocated her
knee I remember that before and then I
went up after her and I was just like
[__] um and then they have this
ridiculous you know when you get to the
tree line you suddenly realize how fast
you're falling I think it was like 17
feet per second or maybe 11t I can't
remember but it was really fast it was
like basically you
know jumping off of a of a basketball
rim like how fast you'd come down it had
to be a little bit slower right right oh
no cuz you're not reaching terminal
velocity I don't [__] know so all I
know is when you hit the ground what you
were supposed to do is look straight
ahead because for some reason if you
look down at your feet what you were
going to do they were worried you'd pick
your feet up too quickly and somehow
break your legs so what you had to do is
look straight ahead and as right as you
hit the ground you're supposed to do
this little [__] like collapse down
and then this big ridiculous bring your
both your legs straight up in the air
and then over to your
side I don't I don't know why I doubt
that they still have people do that and
I did what everybody else did is I came
down and the second my feet hit the
ground I did a face
plant right into the grass and my buddy
grabbed the uh the mic from the person
and called me a [__] something like
that what a [__] or something in the
um in the in the radio um so
yeah there you go so I did it and what
are you basing chicken [__] American on
huh oh you tough guys over there with
your fish and chips have you done it yet
500 you I there's nothing you can some
if I don't want to do something I I I
wouldn't do it there's not money that
you can give me I know you go oh give me
a [__] break no I'm making great
money I got enough money I got enough
money I'm good to take my life in my
[__] hands
no that's one of those things now when I
was back working at the
warehouse I mean granted I pay somebody
when I was working in a [__]
Warehouse I uh
[__] you know let's
see how much would they I mean if they
gave
me literally if you gave me $400 you
would have doubled my pay for the week
so I would have done
that let's see let's go back to the
building to climb up that
building how much money would they have
to give me uh when I was working in the
warehouse uh
$800 um and that now for that that
building uh I would say uh yeah I just
wouldn't do
it no I'm all right I'm all set I'm all
set I you know I should actually send
you guys that video um so it's not that
I hate height sir I
hate um risking my
life to that level if there's like a
parachute or something like
that there's a bungee cord or there's
like a [__] safety line that that's
fine but you know going up that Tower
where I have to unhook the safety line
and then hook it back up and there's
wind and [__] [__] that that's too much
of a risk I wouldn't do that but
uh you
know I don't [__] I don't know what the
[__] I'm talking about all right College
cooking dear Billy boad D oh that's a
great one what a great one Billy Billy
boy oh [__] I got to wrap this up this
guy's coming in 12 minutes uh I'm sure
everyone is blowing you up to make
another cooking video so don't worry
this isn't that I'm a college student I
know you've lived like a college student
into your early 30s from past stories
about living with Bobby Kelly oh dude we
weren't living like college students we
were living like [__]
animals uh do you have any menu
suggestions besides pasta what would you
mix together I'm pretty creative and I
do all right but I'm open to some
suggestions what's good to throw
together on a budget and on a flly
you know what dude I would go to
um I would this is what I would do I
would go on YouTube and I would ask that
question and you'll find videos and then
just start searching and at some point
you're going to connect with somebody
and I feel like I'm you know dropping
the ball here on the question but like
I'm not a chef I'm not even a cook I'm
really early on this to this myself so
that's what I would do there's a bunch
of old episodes of Mario Mario bal's
molto Mario m o t Mario um I really
suggest watching those just watch the
guy I used to just watch the show and
just by watching it you learn things and
you start to see how things are
made
um and and uh the big thing is not
having you just have to to learn [__] in
life you got to have
the the mindset of like I'm you know I'm
going to [__] this up probably the first
time and that's all right and then I'll
get a little better like the pasta I
already just even just running it
through the pasta maker I already have
like three three [__] things that I'm
not going to do the next time um and by
the way somebody gave me a great tip
when you after you've uh kneaded the
dough and you're putting it through your
pasta maker be sure to to douse like
both sides with flour be liberal with
the flour cuz if you don't it's going to
tear it could tear when you're in there
cuz it's supposed to be like sticky and
elastic at the same time and uh when you
run it through there
um yeah you could you could possibly
have some issues and it tears and it's a
big [__] pain in the ass and then you
gets sad you feel like a [__] failure
and you're not you had the balls to try
it so I would uh I'd go that Rachel
Ray's got a great bunch of great ones
from back in the day everybody always
makes fun of her but she what did she I
make 20 minute meals that little [__]
laugh she do I used to watch her [__]
all the time that's great [__] for
probably where you're at but I I would
also Google some stuff like that um but
it's great as a college student if you
start to learn how to cook if you start
to learn how to cook right now and you
do it religiously you are going to be a
[__] beast compared to the average
person um by the by the time you're in
your 30s dude forget it if you add like
[__] like learning how to how to make a
pie crust because then then you can make
turkey pot pie you can make kich you can
make all of this [__] you start making
homemade pasta forget it it's [__]
over then you learn how to do all this
other stuff I forget what I mean I made
it with Nia I was really concentrating
on making the pasta she did the bolones
and then she did the whole milk sauce
thing but I just was watching her do
that where you heated up some butter and
some flour and then you heated up some
milk then you poured the whole thing
together instead of using like uh
ricotta
cheese um or any of that type of [__] um
you use this really rich milk thing was
was too much the [__] dish was like
it almost tasted like a dessert it was
so [__] good but um I didn't know how
to do [__] when I was your age so I
think it's great that you're doing it um
you know you want how about Blue Apron
sign up for that [__] and just you know
steal some of their meal ideas and then
expand on them if there's a if there's a
style of cooking that they give you then
you go on
YouTube and uh you just start looking at
recipes about that like you know what I
I don't know anything about which is
weird because I love the food is any
sort of Asian
style um cooking I actually smoked some
ribs and I and I had this uh this
dipping sauce that was like a a you know
whatever CH uh Chinese or Japanese
influence you know with the [__] soy
sauce and all that and it was and I was
in a part of the grocery store that I
never went to and it was the [__] it
tasted great and uh that's something I
was kind of thinking this year I want to
get down pasta and and start to have
some Asian uh type dishes in there so if
there's anybody out there that can help
me with that I'd appreciate it so
anyways the guy's coming here in8
minutes I got to upload this [__] um
I'll talk to you
later what's up everybody and welcome
back to the anything better podcast NFL
Edition going into Wild Card super
Wildcard Weekend they're calling it
super because there's a Monday night
game I mean there's Saturday G I mean
it's Sunday games um the regular season
is over everybody so now it is let's be
honest Paul there's a lot of teams out
there that have no business being in the
playoffs They just added all of these
rounds to make money that's why it's
super so they can get bigger Yachts
bigger mountains of cocaine and a lot
more horse but you know what Paul we
have nothing better to do so let's talk
about these games well what team do you
think doesn't belong
there um
Texans uh the Dolphins couldn't put away
the
bills uh the Rams what are they going to
do and the Buccaneers even though I like
Baker Mayfield like this whole they this
is like
t-ball how many second place teams Paul
are you gonna invite to the dance you
weren't pretty enough yeah you're
staying home on prom night but not on
super Wildcard Weekend Paul yeah you
know what next we should have started a
flag football game we probably could
have played the [__] Packers next
year it's gonna be super super wild
super duper two wacky wild weeks of it I
love how they added an extra week of
football and then like nobody played it
was like they should call that backup
weekend that's a great point it's like
it's an extra week and momes and Kelsey
are in hoodies last I love it and they
didn't play and the owner still had to
pay him it's fantastic although they
would have just done that in week 16
yeah Paul you got a lot of buttons a lot
of buttons and they're all buttoned up
you joining the military huh you got
somebody coming by checking out uh you
know with a white
glove um dude did you just wake up I'm
sorry no I had a cup of coffee I'm being
a douche go ahead I'm sorry no uh
speaking of white glove there was this
North Korean chick on Rogan and Rogan
goes what is it what is like what like
constitutes somebody getting like
executed in your country and she goes
every every room in the house has to
have one of the Kims a portrait of one
the Kims either Kim Jong-un or the son
or whatever right and at any time that's
their live love laugh signs yeah and at
any and he have to have it in every room
and she said to Rogan that the
government could break in in the middle
of the night at two o'clock in the
morning and they come in and they
actually put a white glove on and if
there's dust if those pictures aren't
like pristine and perfect you could be
imprisoned for life or
executed yeah you can't you're not he's
not going to
last um yeah anyway you can't you can't
you can't be doing that to people
speaking eventually they Rebel let's get
into fun let's get into F hey Paul you
know what I don't know something about
this weekend feels a little
super uh first guys we got a shout out
funny is nobody says super anymore it's
kind of funny how you don't think about
the Super Bowl Super Bowl well no but
I'm saying like it's just they said it
so long ago and you don't really think
about like no one goes
Super hey pay Paul out want to meet to
tomorrow at five o'clock super like
nobody says that super like what if they
called it the far out Bowl you know
that's when they
name then this would be the far out
[__] Wild Card Weekend man The Groovy
The Groovy Bowl baby the out ofite bowl
out of sight
Bowl the mama hand
Bowl oh it's kind of weird that they and
I've never really thought about that but
Paul I'm not a thinker um all right
everybody we got a shout out our sponsor
it's B MGM everybody we got a new
promotion this week we got a new
promotion for super Wildcard Weekend
here's what here's what you do you could
bet $ five and you get 158 instantly
place your first bet to the BET MGM
sports book okay uh through your mobile
I don't understand how they make money
doing that and uh you give at least five
dollar okay you give at least 5 you will
receive 158 instantly in additional uh
winnings regardless of your wages
outcome what you do is you download the
bmgm app uh you visit bgm.com you sign
up and you deposit at least $ Five Doll
into your newly created account you
place a wager in that account at least $
five dollar uh at standard odds price
you use our obviously using our bonus
code bur B RR very simple once you have
placed the bet you receive $ 58 in bonus
bets regardless of the outcome of your
wager there you go everybody $5 get you
158 so you could enjoy super Wild Card
Wild Card Weekend super Wild Card
Weekend we have a lot I'll tell you Paul
I am [__] amped up for this
weekend I am it's gonna be super dude
Wildcard Weekend is my favorite I like
Wildcard Weekend better than divisional
I this is my favorite you're a positive
guy you [__] like everything you like
you like bad weather who does I'm a
weather guy bill it's snowing back here
I [__] love it yeah I'm up to my
[__] ass in snow that I have to
shovel and you you love it Paul I I
swear to God I H you're like a 35y old
Santa Claus you're just in a good
[__] mood your beard hasn't gone
white yet you know listen well here's
what it is paully Christmas you live
longer that way God willing knock on
wood um oh Paul you're going to be
you're going to be the guy everybody
wants to
be he's always in a good mood I think
that's why he beats the book every year
he just he thinks
positive listen three years in a row
what's it going to take until I get my
recognition how many I mean you should
get some sort of a trophy a ring
something a concession call I feel like
are they gonna go Donald Trump and
they're not gonna concede and say that
you cheated I keep getting the franchise
tag on this thing I'll do it
again I'll do it again I'll [__] do
it again you want me to do it again
right I don't think anybody's betting
against you dude three years in a row
that's not a FL by 17 games I think I
beat it by 17 or 16 and a half come for
me I'm Coming For You Stephen A I'm
coming for you you you over three years
16 or this year 16 this year last year
was like why did you wait till the
second week and be like mathematically I
can [__] I got him I thought you were
only up by like three or four games
that's incredible hang on one second hey
I'm doing a podcast let me call you
right back
let's get this bill the first
game oh it's gonna be a super one Paul
it's gonna be far out by the way Andrew
how are we doing this buddy are we are
we picking each like there's only a
certain amount of games are we just
picking this together what's going on
here uh yeah whatever you want to do
last year last year I think you guys
just picked every game together all
right so the first game we got is we got
the Cleveland Browns we got the got we
got the Cleveland Browns on the road
something oh Cleveland is actually a a
road favorite two and a half they're
laying two and a half in Houston against
the
Texans I like the Texans what I like the
Texans oh you didn't like that I like
the Texans no no no I was trying to hear
what you said um oh it's a tough one Joe
flacko you know is a that's right I keep
forgetting Joe
flacko and who's who's having more fun
than him Paul
it's a tough
game let's be honest it's not the
greatest game on the
list what you call it super gun to my
head yeah I'll take the Texans at home
that rookie quarterback had a great I
don't want to do I want to root for Joe
flacko well you could you could pick
your pick I make my pick oh okay I just
needed your permission I'm
sorry I'm going to take the Texans you
talked me out of it listen I don't give
a [__] cuz this doesn't count against my
record I just want to enjoy the game so
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm H I'm goingon to
go with the Browns because I like Joe
flacko I like the Browns you know the
Texans I mean they're still an expansion
franchise to me that's the Houston
Oilers and they went to [__]
Nashville you know what you know what
you're right I'm actually I gotta go
with the better defense I do like TJ
strout I like what the Texans did but
they had to win the last game to get in
or whatever I'm going to take the Browns
too I like that pick I think the Browns
better defense and Joe Flo's experience
uh I'll take the Cleveland Browns too
listen my last what what if he just went
on a [__] run imagine he won the
Super Bowl dude that's what I'm saying
how how fun would that be dude if Joe
FCO won the Super Bowl with the Browns
that would be they make a movie out of
that dude yeah that's that'd be ring
number two and then he's in the hall but
it's not happening um oh Paul I mean
this is a super weekend I mean I I mean
I I think that would be pretty super if
he did that I'll go as far as to say
only one Team ony
B only only one team on this list what
do we got two four six eight 10 only one
team out of these 12 teams is going to
the Super Bowl in this one and the other
team ain't on this list because they
ain't playing this weekend yeah um all
right I like I'm with still with this py
guy he's throwing the ball before they
even turn around it's like everybody
does that they do that at all levels
it's called quarterback yeah it's called
being a quarterback what you supposed to
wait till the DB back's also
looking do you realize level skill that
taks um I'm not saying the 49ers are a
bad team I'm just
saying they just that they're they're
they're selling this kid all right okay
so I'm going with the Browns minus two
and a half I'm going with the Browns
minus two and a half too I like that I'm
[__] Joe Flaco that's my guy I'm
[__] I'm going with the Browns I'm R
for them in the AFC all right AFC so
both of us are going with the Browns
next game by the way I was like one in
seven last year's playoffs I need a
bounceback playoff here I was terrible
well you put your feet up on the table
you beat the book you were feeling good
you lit the cigar cig year was over I
lit a cigar too
early gather around let me tell you how
to make money in this business Paul
you're own four right now
what Paul you lost all the you lost all
the playoff whispering in your ear like
[__] George W on 911 you get that
look on your face
uh all right next game we got the
Dolphins plus four and a half at
Arrowhead uh against the Chiefs ah we
all know what's going to happen in this
game I know they got Nick Crow the whiz
kid and this and that and the Chiefs are
struggling and
be Travis Kel's going to be stomping
around in the end zone [__] blowing
kisses to uh you know his girlfriend
Taylor Taylor Swift Taylor Swift the
biggest gangster in [__]
entertainment today she's beating all
those bastards Paul she's Bea them I got
take the Chiefs I got to see it it's one
of those where I gotta see it it's I
gotta see the Chiefs lose they're not
gonna I don't think Super Bowl defending
Super Bowl champs they rested it up last
week I like the Chiefs as
well all right that brings us to the
Steelers and the
bills okay Buffalo Bills finally living
up to their potential big win last week
Paul they beat the Miami Dolphins down
there in
Miami reminded the dolphins of who they
are they're a destination city for a
vacation there a place where you go
after you get your pilot's license to
consider trafficking cocaine into this
country what they are not Paul is a
professional football
City I'm going to take I'm sick of them
living off the [__] undefeated
Dolphins from 1972 Paul there was 50 two
[__] years ago enough already they
had two white running
backs with Tom celic
mustaches they
did nobody ever did it since man listen
I think the Buffalo Bills I think the
Buffalo Bills are going to beat the
Steelers I think the Buffalo Bills are
going to go to the Super Bowl but I do
not however I don't think they're gonna
beat the Steelers by 10 so I'm taking
the points I think the Bills win the
game I don't think they win it by more
than 10 I like the Steelers getting
points on the road Mike Tomlin team is
tough another winning season uh listen
it's the Pittsburgh Steelers it's one of
those franchises that just show up it's
just a great franchise I love the 10
points we're starting 10 I have to agree
with you I like the 10 points too uh I
keep feeling like Josh Allen's gonna
have like his Breakout game where he
gets on the same pages with with with
what's his face he keeps overthrowing
him there Stefon Diggs it's going to
happen one of these weeks Paul one of
these weeks I feel like in the playoffs
they're going to have a blood
bath I love that so you kind of think
it's going to happen
early and the Steelers you know the
Steelers they're like this is what we're
doing and they don't make halftime
adjustments they don't fire head
coaches they they don't listen to the
American Heart Association I'm trying to
work this out Paul I'm doing the math
all right you're confusing me here you
how can I enjoy this super Wildcard
Weekend if if you're in my ear like that
super duper super
duper you jive
turkey
um oh why am I gonna do this this is
stupid I'm gonna take the Buffalo Bills
I just feel like they're going to score
a lot of touchdowns and they're G to be
[__] talking to the camera like that
coach of the Eagles and then you know
probably next week they're going to lose
but I think this week they're going to
make a statement everybody's going to be
like and [__] back in August that's
probably what's going to happen I I I I
like Josh Allen Stefon Diggs they
finally get they play a little hurry up
Collinsworth called it last week he's
like is it me or does he play better
when they when they [__] they go
faster he dropped the f bumb nobody
heard it because he got such a grably
voice I'm gonna take the bills minus 10
at
home um that's what I'm what's what I'm
gonna do son of a [__] all right bills
got the bills son of a [__] playing 10
I got the Steelers getting 10 um I think
the bill Win It by like six all right
next game Packers Cowboys Cowboys are
seven and a half Point favorites in
Dallas against the Packers uh and Jordan
love good team man it's a tough one it's
a tough spread too I hate that half a
point yeah and uh both of these teams
are a little wishy-washy
Paul like if you were going to rob a
bank you're not going in with either one
of these teams they're not sitting in
the getaway car
when you come out of the bank with with
the with the bag of money are they are
they gonna be there or they not that is
perfect I am not robbing a bank with the
Cowboys or the Packers or the
Packers convenience store
maybe I'll I'll steal some M&M's with
the Packers and the Cowboys but I am not
I am not going Federal with these [__]
no
um you know what just because it's fun
I'm going to take it P super why can't I
have a good time I'm going to go with
the Packers getting seven and a half I
really like Jordan love I'm and I'm
really hoping that he's going to be uh
continue the tradition of incredible
quarterbacks in Green Bay because this
is another thing too Paul like what you
watching here Brett Favre to Aaron
Rodgers and then if Jordan love does it
I mean you're talk I haven't seen Paul
we've never seen that that's like Ruth
garri they're all the way up to Mickey
mantel Paul I was listening I was
listening to something on the radio and
and this guy called in and he said
something iot deio they're up to dagio
sorry sorry New York 718 sorry he said
um he said something that's why our show
is the best because we give the best
information but here's the deal and
we're
humble a little bit you are the
humbleness come the Paul you beat the
book three years in a row I mean I I
can't believe you're [__] not wearing
the best handicapper in the country no
you gotta stay in the business in the
business I'm the best handicapper in the
business um when we do Vegas Paul I want
to make sure that crowd gives you your
[__]
respect app put respect On this man's
name that's gonna be such a fun show put
a little respect on no um Aaron Rogers
stayed on the they said holding a
clipboard as they say behind Brett f for
two years getting frustrated learn the
system then this kid learn the system I
actually think it makes sense for teams
with a good quarterback that's halfway
or kind of towards the end draft a Young
quarterback and let the kids sit on the
bench for two years and learn the to
learn the system I think that's why you
know these guys that come in and they
just get thrown to the Wolves no I I
don't know why they do that either no I
also don't know why they go forward on
fourth down there's a lot of things Paul
I don't understand anymore but I I've
let go of them I'm still gonna bring
them up it's like a kid a kid starts a
quarterback for BYU he wins a big bowl
game and next thing you know he's
playing on Sundays starting against the
[__] against the Eagles it's like
it's not going to work it's not going to
work well this time of year I think it
does work against the Eagles speaking of
which I shouldn't have used Eagles I
knew I shouldn't have used Eagles all
right uh I'm gonna actually I'm gonna
actually go opposite bill on this one I
think Dak Prescott and CD lamb are
really on the same page I think the
Cowboys win this game by 10 or more I
think they're GNA Rush this Young
quarterback and I hope they're on the
same page it's the [__] 19th game
18th game of the season they're wearing
the same uniform he goes like this when
he's open but they're clicking big is
what I'm saying unlike unlike and that
guy well actually Diggs and them are
coming along too but I like the Cowboys
to win by 10 I'm GNA take the Cowboys as
much as it hurts me to say that as a
Giants fan um next game we got the
Rams oh dude this is a
game staford Matthew Stafford going
against his old team oh [__] in Detroit
in Detroit man that I got the Lions
because they disrespected uh uh Jared
gof and I also I also so I I loved you
know as much as I [__] hate the way
they call some of these games I love
that he went for it again on the
two-point conversion against the was
against the Cowboys that game yeah I
like that I like that he went for it
again like [__] you this is what we're
doing I like that coach I'm with you
100% I love the lions in this game I
love the lions in this game this is a
jaroff Revenge game I love it what's the
coach of the Lions I keep looking it
up Dan Campbell I want him to do a
wrestling
promo yeah he's the Triple H of [__]
head coaches you know you just look you
know the guy played the
game no he's great he's great he goes
and then when we're on our way up we're
going to bite their kneecaps on the way
up he just said some [__] and everyone's
like all
right yeah yeah he's he's going in you
know what he is he's like he's like the
third lead in like the Predator
movie could just see him in there he
takes Jesse the B's part I love that guy
um but it's going to be interesting as
far as like
um this is a huge challenge for them
even though they're they're they're
three-point favorites I just feel like
the experience with the coach and I
think Matthew Stafford at this point is
still a better
quarterback proving himself the guy's
got a ring I can't I can't argue that
can't argue who am I I hey Paul you know
you're just the guy who beats the book
no no you're right the best in the
business Paul I think I think Matthew
Stafford is slightly better but I think
the lions are a better team and the LI
scote Pippen of this show am I going to
start to resent you after a while when I
don't get the ball at the end of the
game
um we both love the line piing I'll be
honest with you I think the line's too
low I think the Lions win the game by a
touchdown
no hey Paul I mean that would be super
because I'm taking the Lions I'm Tak the
LI what a super Wild Car weekend that
would be all right this brings us Paul
to a game that Jake The Snake Jak Jak
the snake coming in by the way ladies
check out the stubble the man is single
the man is available and he very quietly
Paul very quiet
you know what you are Paul you're you're
like [__] you're the Teflon Dawn
you're out there with the canary yellow
suit talking this guy right
here this guy right here he's got the
president's phone number I like the
stubble Jake you're looking good bud
thanks one one spill stamped it I I knew
I had to keep it you got to keep it dude
get a little Swagger that's what you
need man you you're [__] crushing it
what do you got for us thank you um you
know just kind of put in here by uh by
Andrew but I think you guys are on to
something with those picks um I
especially agree with the Chiefs one I
think that's a tough match up for Miami
it's going to be like zero degrees there
too uh yeah they're not gonna play well
in that they're gonna try to shut down
Tyreek Hill though Tyreek coming back to
his house though so you're liking what
we we what we're doing so far yeah maybe
um with the Lions Rams I'm a little bit
on the Rams but you guys kind of kind of
won me over with that argument about the
the Lions they're going to be amped up I
think it's the first time they made the
playoffs in quite don't listen to us hey
Jak any uh Jake do we have any injuries
is there any anybody anybody out anybody
hurt uh not that I know of um I think if
anything the injuries are going to be in
the Eagles game um I saw Herz and AJ
Brown got injured in that Giants game
yeah um but it seemed like that they're
gonna play is they're gonna play yeah
right playoffs you know people don't sit
out as much you know um but yeah
actually like a superhero and this is
just his [__] Alter
Ego a that'd be sweet
[Music]
[Laughter]
I wouldn't lose so much money you
know that's great that'd be sweet all
right okay Jake well thanks for checking
in there you go we got that was [__]
super that was a soup Jake to snake Hot
take Jake all right Paul so now we got
it's a Monday night special what did he
say that that would be wait Andrew this
a Monday night special
right because it's Monday night uh yeah
if you want Monday night special
all right all right dude this Paul you
explain to me where the Eagles were in
November that not only they playing on
super Wildcard Weekend they are on the
[__] road Bill going to Tampa Paul
lot of titty bars let me ask you this
lot of titty bars Bill you're a little
older than me you've been watching
football longer than me a little I got
10 years on you youngster when is the
last time you saw a team I'm serious
this is a serious question I'm not even
joking around when is the last time you
saw a team 10 and one in the NFL 10 and
one and then lose every other game but
one after that like did you do you
remember that or no without a major
injury I think they're hurt
Paul I think and they're just not
telling people because you
know they they have a they have a solid
coach can't call him great till they win
it right is that fair um can't call him
great till they win it yeah all he's
done is premium blend remember that show
Cony Central um
listen I think that this is the game
that they
need uh I think even injured that
they're going to go in there and they're
going to uh they're going to out
football on Paul that's just what's
going to happen they're going to be
better on special teams that just
they're just going to be better in all
facets of the game I love Baker Mayfield
and all of that but I kind of feel like
everybody down there is
surprised that they are in the playoffs
where the Eagles are kind of like what
the [__] happened we need to write this
ship I just feel like they're going to
be more playing desperate like we can't
go out like this the only thing Paul is
there's just a lot of titty
bars in
Tampa and that's something that we need
to consider it it
is there's some taned up titties this is
size and ass down there Paul this is
gorgeous just make make makes a makes a
man abandon a family poll
the amount of friends I
had that went down to Tampa and I was
worried that they were going to choose
Scientology because it started right
there in Clear Water and that's what we
always thought oh oh my God elron harber
got another one that that persuasive son
of a [__] and it wasn't Paul it wasn't
you come down there Paul and You' see
him sitting in the corner in the dark
drinking out of a half coconut a s
Splitters Comedy Club has broken up more
marriages Bobby Jewel has taken more to
titty bars no that that guy's not there
anymore oh he isn't all right does Baker
Mayfield pull this off to the Tampa okay
okay if we're just going
fun if we're just going fun I'm a baker
Mayfield guy I [__] love the guy all
right you've been on him all year and
you were right all year I've been on
this guy since what's his face is coling
what's his face is [__] on him ohow
him on his show yeah Callin
coward so you know right there I rooted
for him they have a [__] guy in in
the the the the sports business
Paul he's not as good as you Paul you're
the best in the business okay but I'd
say he's number two he's in the playoff
right I need to see he brought on the
show and continued to [__] on
him looking like he can't even throw a
ball leads the Browns to the playoffs
and gets him a victory colins still
trashes him gets bounced around to the
Panthers the Rams what's going on blah
lands on his feet and this is happening
and as far as I know Paul the man's
still getting no respect you know what
I'm going to do Paul just for the
[__] fun of it I'm gonna take the
Buccaneers plus three even though I like
the eagles and I like Nick he I like
that
coach
um why not Paul hey Paul that's that's
that's the pregame speech why not us
here's the
thing I think the Buccaneers I'm with
you I agree
something is really broken in Philly you
don't lose five out of six of your last
games when you're 10 and one and the
coach just looks completely [__]
baffled in the press conference he's
going we need to dig down deep something
is wrong Jaylen guys are hurt he's not
baffled what he forget how to coach
football they're [__] hurt Paul I'm
telling you they're hurt and he has to
sit there and take one for the team
everybody's he can't go out everybody's
hurt you're speaking in
hyperbole I'm with you I'm G take
Buccaneers I think the Buccaneers are
going to [__] I think Nick is is
taking one for the team by saying you
know we got to dig down we got it blah
blah blah we got blah blah blah blah
because he's not going to say three of
my linemen can barely stand on their
[__] big toe because of this and that
and [__] this guy's got a hamstring
he's not gonna do that Paul well um Chad
ooo what's his name Chad Johnson was on
inside the NFL and he said something
best [__] show the best show out
there right now and he said something I
completely disagree with he goes and and
you could tell the other hosts were like
what he goes the Eagles are playing
posum and once goes what you don't play
posum and lose home field advantage you
don't play posum to lose a
bye you don't go maybe posum was the
wrong wrong word hey Bill Let's make our
road rougher to really throw people off
let's add some drama to this no um the
thing is they're just yeah I I like
Baker Mayfield they're flying high down
there in Tampa uh but we got to do a a
special so we'll take the Bucks and the
three points oh now we're getting into
money I was going with my heart with
Baker Mayfield I'll tell you Paul I got
I have a feeling the bills and the
Eagles are going to try to reestablish
themselves this weekend they want to
beat the [__] out of both teams well the
bills are already reestablished the
bills have won the last four I
think what the [__] they were supposed
to [__] run away with the division
the whole question was supposed to be
can they get past the
Chiefs oh that's going to be a good AFC
champ nobody nobody can [__] remember
like [__] four months ago drives me
crazy uh what do you think you Andrew
what's the under
over I hate the under over 43 I was
thinking it was going to be low scored
it's all right so the people are saying
it's low scoring they want you to jump
on the hook and take the over I might do
it you want to take the over you want to
ro for points tease it up if you want
change the odds a bit i' say tease it
down and go over or yeah either way
either
way hey I'm a straight shooter I don't
[__] tee [__] all right you know
where you stand with me no you want to
just take the
over uh we never take the over we always
take the under well if that [__]
Eagles defense shows up and they just
shut him down then they got to score
like [__] 35 of the
points how many touchdowns is 43 uh four
fi
goal four in a field goal six seven time
6 is
42 six [__] and a field
goal Paul I I I'll never figure you out
Paul I will never figure you out every
time I think you're smart you say
something dumb every time I think you're
dumb you say something smart who are you
Paul you are I'm the best handicapper in
the business
baby you want hey you want to do the
under you weren't even close
Paul yeah four is
28 10 Time 4 is 40 four is 28 I don't
know I got confused to how many teams
each team I don't know let's do this
Paul let's just let's let's slow it down
let's not do the under
over let's stop doing addition and
multiplication too all right let's stop
that too let's do the Buccaneers plus
three getting three starting with
points let's do Baker Mayfield to throw
one
and let's do Jaylen Herz to throw
one I think that's a doable fun
thing uh some reason I just pictured him
running one in you got he's gonna have
to throw one they're both gonna have but
he's hurt he's not gonna run right all
right let's let's do that okay hey Paul
and you have yourself a super weekend so
we're gonna have Buccaneers getting
three Jaylen herdz to throw one Baker to
throw one and there you go it put some
money in your pocket what else you want
all right Paul I got one now we have to
talk about
something I mean Mount
Rushmore of today's coaches basically
just Nick Sabin
retires arguably the greatest college
football coach ever Seven Rings who the
[__] else has
seven yeah Nick Sabin and Bill bellich
both leaving B bich it's it's it's
officially
done but that was a little more Mutual
was that was a little Mutual right
bellich wanted out too right like he was
a little
done yeah I I think so it it never ends
well no but he would have if listen he
if he was fired they would have done
that Monday I think they talked and I
think I heard no they there was no there
was no way we were going to fire him I
think no it was an unbelievable run
and it is over but I'm hearing some
Rumblings I'm hearing some Rumblings
that are gonna make Jake The Snake happy
I'm hearing that bellich wants uh Justin
Herbert and that Chargers team wants to
come to the warm weather oh my God I
can't even tell you how much I would
enjoy it it would be great to us if he
went in there and he got them their
first uh far out Bowl Super Bowl sorry
uh Championship dude if Bill bellich
goes to [__] Sofi and wins a Super
Bowl in Los Angeles that would be the he
said I'd love if we hired Vel oh vel's
on the market oh they that's right the
Titans fired
Vel yeah Andel to the Pats Vel could go
to the Pats yeah I know um this just
it's no and it's not that I don't like
Mike Rael I mean it's it's I love Mike
Rael it's just it's just uh you know
give me a second to [__] handle this
[__] and sneaky petla what about Pete
Carol bring Pete Carol back back oh oh
here's the thing nobody's doing
that I don't think right now with where
we're at in a lot of
positions and uh I don't know what kind
of well we got the number one draft pick
that that could be
tantalizing but
um you're also following bill bellich it
would be so talk about
[__] uh how you say Appo is that how
you said he had to follow bill parcel's
when he was with the Patriots Pete
Carroll and he and he was just the whole
time he was there he was not Bill bich
he wasn't Pete Carroll like you're not I
mean you're not bill parcel's then he
would come back even with the Super Bowl
ring he would be um not bill
belich yeah does he want to do I don't
think so I mean I if I was him man I'd
want to go back to Southern California
Jake The Snake how would you like Pete
Carroll coming down to San Diego yeah
you want that competition in the bar him
coming around he's got some
stubble I have to get some gum get some
gum yeah you gotta get that jawline
going he goes down there you know meets
a couple of chicks with some daddy
issues next thing you know your your
little well starts drying up he drinks
your
milkshake um you know P Carol one of the
best he's just a little bit older so I
kind of want someone younger to kind of
like pair with Herbert but belich would
be incredible I mean that that's
obviously I would definitely love to
have him well listen I I like the
Chargers way back during the Dan Fouts
air Corel days so that would be great um
they're fans of douchebags you know
what's funny how do you how do you
interview at least when they were down
in San Diego I remember I went down
there were a Patriots hat I was rooting
for the Chargers they weren't even
playing um right the Patriots and they
were just [__] [__] like but the
Bills fans were like that I think it's
just because we were beating everybody
back then but I'll tell you that that
ship is sailed um bich doesn't the best
thing is belich just chooses a team he
wants there's no interview what's he
gonna do drop a [__] handful of rings
on the desk and say where what has your
[__] franchise done you're lucky to
have me you [__]
nuts won none yeah dude and listen would
be great you know Tom Brady went down
south and he won one and then if he goes
down and he wins that would be number
nine Paul number nine and dude going to
going to get having Justin Herbert and
and Austin Eckler and having that Talent
with a guy like belich in that in that
locker room oh you don't want to play
the Chargers oh you think Paul's on the
Chargers before if bellich goes every
week this is what's funny everybody was
saying that he's finished and he's this
and he's that now that he's on the
market everybody's F oh we we should get
that guy stupid it's the same with
Herbert they're all trashing him until
until their team needs a quarterback
they and as you see on social media
they're like trade for Herbert how are
they trashing the guy the guy got hurt
it's unbelievable you'd be surprised oh
that's right people are [__] idiots
yeah I forgot sometimes I forget that I
mean You' think I'd learned from the
example of myself I got what I got one
for you Bill Sneaky Pete to the Pats
Mike Vel your defensive coordinator how
happy would you
be um with a first I don't listen that
would be great but I I I don't think
Pete wants to start over the thing about
it is is you're starting over with the
Patriots where the Chargers you know
you're just trying to get the car back
on the road but they got they have the
Personnel um I'm trying to think I know
that guy from Atlanta got
fired I loved when he yelled at that
other coach everybody's like what a dick
it's like listen he's emotional he has
to sell his house he knew he was getting
fired he thought maybe you know maybe
they could sneak one more in there and
he wouldn't have to pull his kids out of
the local school system yeah and then
that guy just [__] stomped on
him he kept going you know I just
thought of something so funny I just
thought of bellich and Sneaky Pete in
the same waiting room to interview for
the Chargers and Pete sneaky Pet's like
hey
Bill b bill goes in first sneaky Pet's
just pacing around P hey Bill you know I
still wake up with morning wood what
about you no Viagra I'll [__] them all
oh [__] want to race up the
stairs oh you know I uh I wake up
sometimes with some wood I know it's an
end of an error dude listen I mean what
other team has had a better quarter of a
century run than the Patriots the nobody
yeah I mean it was fantastic and and
it's it's over and uh you know it's
weird it's like I'm sad that it's over
but there's also like the level PA the
the the years that
aged as much as we went to the Super
Bowl all of those [__] times and all
of that stuff but there's a zillion
times we went to the
playoffs during those 20 years and just
you know living and dying on every
[__] play and most of the times
losing you know even with all the
success we won the title six times and
people talk about oh you lost to the
Giants and Eagles it's like we [__]
lost to the Ravens a couple of times we
lost that one to the Colts when they
stole our offense those [__] [__]
and we lost some bad ones not even
getting to the Super Bowl people forget
about all of those dude that was that
one game the Ravens the their first
offensive play ran it up the gut for
like 90 yards we got stomped in our own
house I mean that one that was that was
a humiliating loss there was there was
some but you know and then you got to
[__] shake that off not watch ESPN
for four days it was every [__] year
of that um so now to just sort of
suck it's kind of like you know in
between projects like all right I don't
have to be anywhere
today the movies in the can yeah I can
watch the game it doesn't really matter
I can just [__] relax for a second
but you know the Celtics are great the
Bruins are doing great and um I know
what the Red Sox are doing people are
sitting there going like yeah you know
they keep getting like hey this guy won
the Sai Young five years ago whatever
but I still believe in the Red Sox
though listen good franchises are always
working on just getting better and being
there and that's the nice thing all
those Boston teams you just mentioned uh
are just solid franchises with good
people in the upper in the higher office
that try to make the team better that's
what it is yeah cam has been crushing it
for the Bruins the amount of people that
we lost craie and Patrice berser on and
after that that regular season and that
that unbelievable disappointment in the
first
round um we came right back with new
personnel and we we had we set the
league on fire now we're going through a
little you know back and forth here
right now but we we're still doing great
brought L cheich back you know so people
stop pushing us around I love what's
going on out there franchises like the
Steelers like there are just certain
franchises that just are always they're
just always you're gonna have a couple
bad years you're gonna have a couple bad
years but then you come back
um hope oh God hopefully the Knicks the
Knicks are hot right now hottest team in
the NBA that trade we made is helping
but I can't I gotta just I gotta keep it
down I gotta just keep it I gotta I I'm
gonna look at you from now on when you
talk about the
Knicks
you notice how I parlay that into good
franchises and then I said that Nicks
are doing good right now Paul you are
dairo and casino trying to land Sharon
Stone just [__] give her a jewels and
let her leave she never loved you Bob my
[__] money oh she was the worst what
one of the top performances ever for by
a female I've ever seen ever I mean she
should have got a [__] Oscar for that
one that was dude Ginger are you kid I
think everyone was just they were so
[__] upset for her you know showing
her Goods there with uh the movie before
that oh Basic Instinct Basic
Instinct it was a funny part of Michael
Douglas's
career doing those [__] uh sex
Thrillers just grabbing women bending
them
over tearing their [__] clothes off
get out [__]
you he was the
hero oh [__] uh
all right well there we go there we have
it there there we have is that it we're
GNA end on Michael Douglas bending over
the what's her face on the
couch we got uh it was the 90s she was
wearing thigh highs he was obviously
what were you wearing thigh high for I
don't know because I wanted to look
nice he was old too he was still old
like he just got through that like if
Michael Douglas was five years after
that it wouldn't have been all right
yeah you know you it was like a
three-year period if you did a movie
with Michael Douglas you were getting
bent over a
[Laughter]
couch [__] Streets of San Francisco
Music what he's all psyched getting
those scripts let's see what we got here
hey save that scene save that scene I
want but then then he did the movie
after that where like Diane Lane
remember that other movie where Diane
Lane's cheating on him and then he like
stalks her and the guy like kills him
she's like banging like like like great
looking Spanish listen there's a reason
why that guy's been working for like 50
straight years I love m s up I'm just
saying I'm just saying yeah I'm just
saying um get out of here you [__]
[__] the anything better podcast has
well me and Bill me and Bill both have
the Browns me and Bill both have the
chiefs bill has the bills I have the
Steelers bill has the Packers I have the
Cowboys bill has problems me and Bill
both have the Lions and me and Bill both
have the Buccaneers Buccaneers and the
uh Monday night special Buccaneers Baker
Mayfield Dan
Campbell uh Justin love Josh
Allen uh what's his face there tippy
toes there on the
Chiefs tippy toes is perfect tippy toes
is did you see Patrick momes you see
that kid imitate him that kid imitate
him oh my I I mean I've been saying that
since the beginning dude he does float
around it's he's light on he's light
lighting his [__] cleats there um and
then I got uh Joe
burrow no Joe Flo Joe burrow Joe
flacko what a sin Joe burrow should be
in this [__] sin all right we got the
Buccaneers getting three we got Baker
throwing one and Jaylen throwing one for
the Monday night special for super Wild
Card Weekend that's how oh it's going to
be it's going to be wacky
Wild funorama Wild Card Weekend um next
week D what would you do if they just
went old school this weekend because
it's super duper wild wacky and they
just had the cheerleaders come out with
like no bras wet
T-shirts and just [__] just went just
call it old school
weekend
old
school no broads no annoying broads they
just what if every week just just to
[__] balance it out how far they went
the other way I mean they were wearing
pink for a whole [__] month for
Seasons right almost a goddamn decade
just to [__] balance it out maybe
they went too far in that direction what
if they just had every Wild Card Weekend
was just chauvinist Wild Card Weekend
and they just went
back I want to kiss you sneaky Peet
chewing extra fast he's [__]
psyched he's got a woman on either
arm he goes up to the cheerlead how you
doing sweetheart I'm gonna [__] both of
them at halftime smacks a cheerleader in
the ass Winks at her uh like to make
some halftime adjustments on
you all right everybody bet
responsibly enjoy super duper freaky
decky and don't forget guys turkey Wild
Card
Weekend the new promotion $5 and get you
158 you place your first bet okay you
will receive five5 you place your first
bet at least five you'll receive $150 I
like how you say dollarars $5 five uh
minimum okay you will receive 158
instantly in additional winnings
regardless of your wages just download
the B MGM app to your device use our
bonus code easy bur bu RR sign up you
deposit at least five and you get 158 in
bonus bets regardless of the outcome of
your wager there you go bet resp hey
everybody keep on
trucking hey everybody that's the super
Wildcard Weekend get ready get ready and
Andrew uh Andrew did you because we
gotta we gotta say this before we get
out of here our prod producer Andrew
themess has uh an incredible record he
shattered shooting one Over the Cuckoo's
Nest one year just one year just one
year just one year don't you know don't
get crazy you know I I did it three
times am I am I protective of my my
record yes I am but Andrew did you want
to throw in any of your like locks
What's the Andrew thus lock of the week
uh the only one that I might put money
on is I actually do like the Cowboys and
I and I that's it shouldn't be but I
just there's too many weapons it's I
just don't think the Packers are going
to do well at home I think it's at least
two scores but that's the only one all
right I took that personally and and the
Lions I'd take the Lions too I don't see
the Rams uh doing much there I actually
think the Dolphins could win but the
only reason I'm not going to take the
Dolphins is the weather I I think
otherwise it's a you know could be a
fluke game that's it nothing exciting
Paul nothing exciting all right well
there you go you heard it there I
remember early in the year all they were
talking about the dolphins look at this
play I mean who runs a play like that
and then I just feel like everybody
figured it out
yeah yeah well why is there an echo am I
the only one hearing an I hear
Echo I like that ladies and gentlemen
gentlemen gentlemen all right let's wrap
this up so people have lives let's get
out of here all right thank you so much
for listening we'll see you next week
enjoy football bet responsibly
salid what